erhard scherfer
es geht den rasen tatsächlich ums geld
und das gleich zweimal heute vormittag
hier im deutschen bundestag und in
beiden fällen geht es um steuer
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger aber auch in einem großen maß für
die wirtschaft zwei gesetzentwürfe
liegen vor auf der einen seite aus den
koalitionsfraktionen und zwar das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 da ist der
hintergrund die hohen energiepreise die
ist ja schon zu beginn des jahres
gegeben hat und dann gibt es einen
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung und
zwar den entwurf für das inzwischen
vierte corona steuer hilfe gesetz und
der hintergrund für dieses entlastung
steckt im namen schon mit drin und da
auch zeit geld ist fangen wir relativ
zügig an mit unserem interview vor der
debatte und ich freue mich dass zum
ersten mal und dieser stelle heute
morgen bei uns sind markus herbrand der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion guten morgen ihn und
christian görke hat hier auch an dieser
stelle seine premiere bei phoenix der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion guten morgen ihnen beiden
am tag nach dem 25 geburtstag von
phoenix ich streue es einfach noch mal
bei dieser vielen dank ich weiß einfach
bei dieser gelegenheit noch einmal ein
fangen wir mit dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz an herr herr
braun herbrand was wen wollen sie
erreichen und wie groß wird diese
entlastung dann tatsächlich sein damit
den mit dem steuerentlastungsgesetz
erreichen wir die bürgerinnen und bürger
insbesondere jedes jahr darum den
grundfreibetrag der rückwirkend
reduziert wird das wirkt sich vor allem
für die einkommen die für die
niedrigeren einkommen aus dass das ist
auch gewünscht so es gibt ja auch andere
gesetzespakete die in diesem entlastungs
paket drin sind das ist sozial sehr
ausgewogen gemacht worden weil die
wirkungen der inflation aus meiner sicht
und aus unserer sicht natürlich vor
allem diejenigen treffen die nicht ganz
so viel verdienen entlastung der
bezieher von kleineren einkommen herr
görg hat er muss ihnen doch quasi das
herz aufgehen da sie das ist natürlich
das herz auf und vor allen dingen wir
sagen wir so die diese entlassungs
gesetze gehen dass wir in die richtige
richtung aber sie sind aus unserer sicht
sozial unausgegoren und sind auch
springen noch zu kurz nehmen wir mal
die pendlerpauschale die wird er jetzt
erhöht ab dem 21 kilometer und es werden
gerade die entlastet die viel fahren und
vor einigen höhere einkommen haben und
insofern kann ich ihnen mal ein beispiel
aus der hauptstadtregion aus meinem
bundesland einfach mal nennen wir haben
300 tausend pendler und von diesen
plänen der koalition wird ein drittel
nicht profitieren und das ist das was
man hier kritisieren muss und deshalb
sagen wir wir wollen einen
paradigmenwechsel wir wollen ein
mobilitäts geld ein mobilitäts geld das
ab dem ersten kilometer natürlich auch
für die die wenig haben gezahlt werden
wäre die nächste frage gewesen was in
ihrer alternativen ideen sind aber wir
können das jetzt einmal durcharbeiten
ich habe die drei entscheidenden punkte
bei diesem gesetzentwurf ohnehin raus
geschrieben grundfreibetrags betrachter
scheint es keinen großen lizenz zu geben
aber entfernungspauschale sie sagen das
gesamte gesetz das gesamte paket sei
sozial ausgewogen herr görg erhält gehen
vor neu ist es nicht weil es einen
bestimmten teil der bevölkerung
bevorzugt mehr geht immer das kann man
natürlich sagen wir haben uns natürlich
auch vorgenommen in diesem paket die
entfernungspauschale insgesamt in den
nächsten jahren noch einmal zu
überprüfen dahingehend was da gemacht
werden kann ich selber komme auch vom
land bei mir fahren die leute auch
teilweise 70 100 kilometer zur arbeit zu
gehen sie ja eigentlich niemand zwingt
so weit zu fahren also man könnte 100
naja man muss aber schon zur arbeit
kommen sie wissen möglicherweise nicht
wo ich herkomme aus der eifel
genau also man muss schon zur arbeit
kommen und insofern ist es schon so dass
die fernpendler zunächst einmal mehr
belastet sind die fern pendlerpauschale
zu erhöhen war ohnehin vorgesehen wir
ziehen diesem zeitpunkt nur vor er gibt
mir recht der kollege es fällt fallen
viele pendler durch das raster und vor
allen dingen die die möglicherweise
wenig steuerzahlen beziehungen überhaupt
keine steuern zahlen müssen die kriegen
gibt keine kompensation und insofern hat
sich hier das muss man mal sagen hat
sich hier die fdp natürlich gegenüber
den grünen und der spd spd linke
durchgesetzt denn die wollten und die
wollen auch ein mobilitäts geld und das
ist dringend nötig diese sagen sie
vielleicht noch zwei sätze weil sie es
jetzt das zweite mal angesprochen haben
zudem mobilitäts geld was wäre besser
daran als an der in diesem fall
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler es
muss versteuert werden
und jeder bekommt es ab dem ersten
kilometer und bei uns gibt es derzeit
überlegungen dies bei zehn cent
festzumachen und im übrigen wird das
nicht wesentlich teurer als das was
jetzt die koalition hier forscht und
herbert warum ist das keine alternative
aus ihrer sicht oder ist es vielleicht
doch eine es ist möglicherweise eine
alternative wir mussten jetzt sehr
schnell handeln wir wollten die leute
schnell entlasten und das haben wir dann
auch gemacht wir werden wie gesagt uns
diese entfernungspauschale insgesamt
noch mal ansehen und insgesamt meine ich
auch müssen wir schlicht daran arbeiten
dass der öpnv besser wird damit die
menschen halt nicht mehr 70 kilometer
oder 100 kilometer mit dem eigenen pkw
fahren müssen aber dann geht es auch
schon los man klotz tiere beim militär
bei der auf fast 100 milliarden und
anstatt wirklich die gleichen beträge
zur verfügung zu stellen um die
verkehrswende zu finanzieren dann war
und man sich in die büsche und das geht
nicht und die finde das sind falsche
weichenstellung und ich hätte das auch
nicht erwartet von der fdp vielleicht
auch von den sozialdemokraten und den
grünen dieser bundestagsfraktion hätte
ich das nicht erwartet
das sind jetzt sachfremde erwägungen in
meinen augen das muss man jetzt
miteinander in verbindung bringen wir
war und zwar daran gelegen jetzt
entlastung sehr schnell entlastungen auf
den weg zu bringen das haben wir mit
diesem gesetz gemacht und das tun wir
auch mit dem anderen gesetz worüber wir
noch sprechen werden mit dem chor oder
steuer hilfe gesetzen
es gibt ja eine menge päckchen faktoren
sind die grund kritik habe ich gesagt
und dann nehmen wir mal dieses eine
päckchen der energie pauschale die ihr
einmalige zeit wird einmalig 300 euro
brutto und netto beträge je nach
steuerklasse zwischen 116 190 euro bei
dieser inflation wird das regelrecht
aufgezehrt und dann für drei für
einmalig und wissen sie was ich
kritisiere dass studenten minijobber
aber auch millionen von rentnern einfach
mal vergessen worden weil sie nicht zu
den erwerbstätigen 10 und auch hier hat
sich die fdp und nicht dass sie denken
ich lobe sie dafür aber eins zu eins
durchgesetzt ja also von fortschritts
koalition kann ich wirklich bei diesen
entwicklungen wirklich nicht reden das
ist ein weiter so nur mit anderen farbe
aber auch ein anderes gesetz worüber sie
jetzt sprechen das entlastungspaket 2 ja
wir sprechen jetzt über das
verfassungspaket wird was noch kommen
wird wir sprechen jetzt über das
entlastungspaket 1 denn machen das ja in
der tat noch aus dem kabinett glaube ich
dreiundzwanzigster zweiter stand also
auch noch gar nicht mit dem krieg zu tun
hat sondern schlicht und ergreifend
diese langen anhaltenden und sehr hohen
inflationswerte zur grundlage hat da
nehmen wir doch mal dieses andere ist
jetzt was heute auf der tagesordnung ist
so wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht geben
sie mir eine chance und eine nach reifen
system
steuerentlastungsgesetz hier am meisten
profitieren ledige mit hohem einkommen
bestimmt das habe ich das richtig
gelesen 170 euro im jahr wenn man ein
einkommen von 6500 euro im monat hat
kann das hinkommen da bin ich ehrlich da
bin ich tatsächlich jetzt über fragt
angesichts der reduzierung des
grundfreibetrages würde ich das in frage
stellen wollen er macht sein also da
würde mich jetzt auch nicht an der
stelle fest langweilige würde trotzdem
noch mal diesen einen punkt was es mit
denen die wenig bis gar keine steuern
zahlen dem punkt den örtlich auch
angesprochen hat wie was nützt der
person in diesem fall diese
steuerentlastungsgesetz einfach um das
zu verstehen die die sind in anderen
gesetzen berücksichtigt über den
heizkostenzuschuss über den über den
kinder zuschuss für von armut bedrohten
kindern das sind andere gesetzes nicht
um das nicht am steuer untersuchen
ich habe ihnen gesagt sie können
aufeinander reagieren
und der rarität da der parität der
paritätische wohlfahrtsverband hat
gesagt dass er ist der regelsatz auf
über 650 euro erhöht werden müssen wir
sind jetzt bei 440 und dann kommt einmal
200 euro dazu und auch möglicherweise
einmal ein
kostenzuschuss dem man auf
parlamentarischem druck der auch der
linken in der spd wir haben das auch
unterstützt jetzt nach gesteuert hat das
sind ja punkte in die richtige richtung
aber sie reichen nicht aus um wirklich
diese problemlagen die wir in
deutschland haben endlich mal sagen wir
mal ab zur also die gegen
finanzierungsfrage will ich jetzt nicht
aufbringen dann sprechen wir gleich über
die vermögenssteuer dann kommen wir also
ob ich nicht mehr rechtzeitig hier weg
doch das schaffen wir schon weil er
wollte ich sowieso ein weil das ist ja
schon eine zentrale zu überspringen wenn
man diese corona steuer hilfe gesetzt
man kommt tatsächlich zu diesem punkt
nämlich der finanzierung ich glaube die
steuer mindereinnahmen beim
steuerentlastungsgesetz das musste mal
müssen sie erstmal bestätigen es sind
ungefähr bei 4,5 milliarden und dem
zusammenhang mit dem mit dem corona
steuer hilfe gesetz liegen wir bei zehn
oder elf milliarden glaube ich sogar
über eine längere strecke wenn ich mich
nicht irre trotzdem soll dieses geld
herkommen
ja wir haben ja der der haushalt ist ja
eingebracht und es wurden die eckwerte
eingehalten die noch von der
vorgängerregierung eingebracht wurden
diese eckwerte sind eingehalten obwohl
wir diese zwei entlastungs paket mit auf
den weg gebracht haben es wird noch
einen ergänzungs haushalt geben der
schlicht und ergreifen aber nur mit
dingen zu tun haben darf die die
wirtschaftlichen folgen des krieges
dieses schrecklichen krieges abfedern
also im grunde genommen ist das haus hat
erich abgebildet aber sie wissen noch
nicht wie es weitergeht weil sie setzen
ja in teilen auch darauf dass durch
indem sie beispielsweise die wirtschaft
entlasten bei dem kroner steuer hilfe
gesetze dass dann die wirtschaft wieder
deutlicher anspringt dass menschen haben
dann auch generiert werden und ein
gewisser weise dann auch den ausgleich
zustande kam die wirtschaft wird
entlastet das sehe ich auch so aber sind
in der regel fortlaufende dinge es gab
ja auch schon corona steuern für gesetz
1 2 und 3 wir verlängern die maßnahmen
jetzt weil die weil die pandemie einfach
länger ist als als wir uns das alle
denken die finanziellen auswirkungen
sind da nicht so fürchterlich in der tat
gehen wir aber auch davon aus dass wir
ansonsten an anderer stelle mehr geld
aufbringen müssten also wir versuchen ja
da
den weg des geringsten widerstandes
sozusagen ganz kurz vorher aufbringen
oder wie habe steueraufkommen
selbstverständlich okay nicht nur neue
steuern auch keine steuererhöhungen
sowieso wenig keine erhöhungen und auch
keine neuen schulden christian görke
warmer finanzminister mal gucken was er
dazu sagt in brandenburg
der kollege lindner finanzminister der
fdp jetzt hat allein in den letzten
monaten in der prognose mehr
steuereinnahmen durch die erhöhten
mehrwertsteuer bei den energieträgern ja
schon prognostiziert
25 milliarden euro die on top kunden und
dann hat die europäische kommission und
das ist normal ein punkt den betriebs
ländern der europäischen union auch
deutschland empfohlen
diese sogenannten zufalls gewinne die
die mineralölkonzerne jetzt durch diesen
preisanstieg den sie möglicherweise auch
selbst forciert haben mal abzuschöpfen
und in europa geht man davon aus dass
ungefähr 200 milliarden euro an erlösen
selbst immer nur 50 prozent davon
versteuert erreicht werden kann für
deutschland prognostizieren wir die
finanzexperten nichtig die fachleute
ungefähr zwischen 15 und 20 milliarden
euro mehreinnahmen schon allein mit
diesen beiden maßnahmen kann man diese
pakete aus finanzieren und dann gibt es
natürlich noch andere möglichkeiten ich
meine die machen schulden
noch löcher und in einer krise muss man
das auch mal aber dass man dafür dass
die aufrüstung damit finanziert und
nicht möglicherweise in die wirtschaft
das lenkt das ist das was wir
kritisieren herr brand direkt gerne also
dass der kollege in die wirtschaft
investieren möchte finde ich wunderbar
gemacht also das nicht so untersagt wird
also wir natürlich dabei die idee der
zufalls steuer findet bei uns keinen
anklang ich glaube das habe ich ja
überhaupt nicht gar nicht richtig
verstanden und mal ganz ehrlich zu sein
ich will das ja so ein begriff ist der
in der tat ja auch nicht besonders
häufig vorkommt den finanzpolitischen
debatten abgriff über gewinn steuer sagt
man auch
so erklären dass die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auch verstehen und ich am
besten auch also nehmen wir die
mineralölkonzerne beispielsweise die
möglicherweise in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten dann doch deutlich über
gewinne gemacht haben so würden der ein
oder andere sagen dass die von diesen
gewinnen eventuell mehr abzugeben haben
wir halten das für keine gute idee
sondern dass ein das ist in unserer aus
unserer sicht ein unzulässiger eingriff
in die marktwirtschaft und kreativ
verband wäre
richtig wenn die europäische kommission
dass die mitgliedstaaten empfiehlt
gesetzgeberisch in die möglichkeit
eröffnet gesetzgeberisch tätig zu werden
hätte ich erwartet und das werden wir
natürlich auch als linke tun im rahmen
des parlamentarischen prozesses dies
natürlich als finanzierung für unsere
vorschläge natürlich mit vorzulegen und
wie gesagt ich bin auch nicht allein
wirklich ökonomen teilweise konservative
ökonomen die ihn mittlerweile sagen es
reicht jetzt wir müssen jetzt hier auch
mal fair und gerecht besteuert wir
wissen aber auch dass wir dann einen
einhelligen vorschlag brauchen auf
europäischer ebene der wird es den wird
es nie geben schon durch dass
die kommission den mitgliedstaaten
empfohlen temporär temporär dies zu
machen und in meiner mario draghi ist
nun kein linker noch sind konservativer
regierungschef der hat die eingeführt
und finanziert damit 44 milliarden euro
seines entlastungspaket es in italien
geht doch oder und an dieser stelle
müssen wir mit diesem gespräch hier
aufhören obwohl sich daran habe dass sie
sich bei ihrem ersten auftritt hier bei
uns über phoenix oben viertel vor neun
vor einer plenarsitzung nicht unwohl
gefühlt haben und wir das ganze wie
üblich noch eine viertelstunde länger
machen könnten aber erst kurz vor 9 und
die bundestagspräsidentin wir gleich die
sitzung eröffnet deswegen bedanke mich
bei ihnen für ihren ersten auftritt hier
bei uns bei ihnen beiden sehr vielen
dank und wünsche ihnen eine
noch muntere debatte wir sind ja sogar
zwei zu diesem thema wie wir hier
zumindest an gerissen haben danke für
heute morgen uns jetzt dürfen sie auch
reingehen und wir meine damen und herren
wir gucken auch in den plenarsaal
reinschauen mal ob wir schon was er
spielen können sehr wohl wir sehen die
bundestagspräsidentin nimmt auch schon
platz und da würde ich doch sagen dann
gebe ich einfach mal rein
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen guten morgen die
sitzung ist eröffnet
ich rufe auf
die tagesordnungspunkte guten morgen
tagesordnungspunkte 19a und 19 b
erste beratung des von den fraktionen
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten entwurfs eines
steuerentlastungsgesetzes
2022 sowie beratung des antrags der
fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem titel mut
zu wesentlichen steuerlichen
hilfsmaßnahmen
für die aussprache
wurde eine dauer von 68 minuten
beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache
und das wort hat der bundesminister
christian lindner
frau präsidentin guten morgen meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wladimir putin führt seinen
schrecklichen verbrecherischen krieg
gegen die ukraine gegen unsere werte von
freiheit und selbstbestimmung und wir
wissen erscheint nicht einmal davor
zurück brutalste gewalt anzuwenden und
grundlegende zivilisatorische werte zu
vernichten und das kann nicht ohne
reaktion bleiben
das hat aber auch wirtschaftliche
konsequenzen für uns und das gilt umso
mehr vor dem hintergrund der gerade in
verschärfung begriffenen neuen
sanktionen die wachstumsaussichten
trüben sich bereits ein der
sachverständigenrat geht davon aus dass
unsere wirtschaft nunmehr nur noch um
1,8 prozent in diesem jahr wachsen wird
zudem sieht er eine inflationsrate von
6,1 prozent
gleichzeitig hat sich der arbeitsmarkt
in deutschland im märz allerdings trotz
des kriegs in der ukraine weiter erholt
angesichts also einer von hoher
unsicherheit geprägten lage ist es ein
gebot ökonomischer und politischer
vernunft das wachstum in deutschland zu
stärken
inflationsrisiken entgegenzutreten und
härten abzufedern
anders als während der korona pandemie
geht es jetzt aber um so mehr um
entschlossenes handeln das aber gezielt
erfolgt wenn wir gehen sorgsam mit dem
geld der bürgerinnen und bürger
und deshalb ist eine unserer
wesentlichen maßnahmen dieses
steuerentlastungsgesetz
wir sichern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
sichern den bürgerinnen und bürgern mehr
geld im portemonnaie und wir sichern den
betrieben liquidität damit stützen wir
langfristig die zuversicht in eine gute
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und ich sage
es klar es ist eine absicht auch der
koalition die bei den menschen ankommen
de gefühlte inflation zu dämpfen denn
das ist ein beitrag gefährliche lohn
preis spiralen zu verhindern
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen später
mutige tat werden wir mit dem vierten
quartal hilfe gesetz noch weitere
erleichterungen auf den weg bringen und
heute mittag werde ich mit robert habeck
öffentlich machen welche zusätzlichen
unternehmenshilfen die bundesregierung
auf den weg bringt nichts tun ist in
dieser lage keine option
mit dem entwurf des
steuerentlastungsgesetzes
2022 den wir jetzt diskutieren geht es
um die bürgerinnen und bürger direkt und
unmittelbar wir wollen sich schnell und
unbürokratisch entlasten wir helfen vor
allem den haushalten die in besonderer
weise von herzen getroffen sind aber wir
nehmen auch die sorgen der breiten mitte
war zur ehrlichkeit gehört aber eines
dazu die mittel des staates sind endlich
darf sich jetzt in dieser situation auch
nicht fiskalisch erschöpfen als
staatliche verantwortungsgemeinschaft
müssen wir uns insbesondere an die am
stärksten
betroffenen wenden und wir müssen
wirtschaftliche struktur brüche
verhindern einen allgemeinen wohlstands
verlust unseres landes infolge von
steigenden preisen für importe könnte
der staat aber nicht dauerhaft
ausgleichen auch das was wir jetzt hier
vorgelegt haben entbindet uns nicht von
einer grundlegenden einer neugründung
der quellen unseres wohlstands durch
marktwirtschaftliche programme durch
öffentliche investitionen und vor allem
durch viele gemeinsame arbeit
ich hilfe bereit punkte hervor erstens
neben den grundfreibetrag an ein
außergewöhnlicher schritt normalerweise
findet unterjährig ja keine anpassung
stadt wir gehen diesen schritt weil wir
eine notwendigkeit einer schnellen
entlastung sehen und weil die
vorgängerregierung die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und insbesondere die
inflation dieses jahres unterschätzt hat
deshalb werden wir jetzt alle
einkommensteuerpflichtigen entlasten
durch den höheren grundfreibetrag und
zweitens werden wir rückwirkend zum
ersten januar den arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag auf 1200 euro anheben der
ist seit elf jahren nicht angefasst
worden und jetzt wird er um 20 prozent
erhöht das ist ein starkes signal und
ich füge hinzu diese maßnahmen wirken
auf dauer sie bleiben und mit der
vorlage des
progressionsvorbehalts
wicklung 20 23 und 24 machen es darf
nicht dazu kommen dass die
tarifentwicklung jetzt bei den
beschäftigten in zuge der lohnrunde dass
die obwohl sie nur die kaufkraft
ausgleicht am ende zu einer stärkeren
steuerlichen belastung führt das wären
in dieser krise automatische
steuererhöhungen die wir abwenden müssen
und drittens kocht auch ein mobilitäts
prämie und die vorgezogene anhebung der
entfernungspauschale auf 38 cent 4,5
milliarden euro ist dieses paket alle
maßnahmen insgesamt die die
bundesregierung dem deutschen bundestag
vorlegt summieren sich auf mehr als 16
milliarden euro in der vollen
jahreswirkung bei einer familie mit zwei
erwerbstätigen ergibt sich dadurch eine
entlastung von 500 euro im jahr wir
handeln in dieser krise und tun das was
notwendig ist und kaum jemand hätte der
ampel zugetraut dass eine der ersten
maßnahmen ein steuerentlastungsgesetz
ist dass mehr netto vom brutto bringt
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
ist der kollege fritz künstler
fritz güntzler gehörte finanzausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren und zuhörer wir sind
froh dass wir heute über ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz debattieren
können die notwendigkeit hat der
bundesfinanzminister ja auch eben
dargestellt habe der
bundesfinanzminister eine ein punkt
würde ich sie doch korrigieren wollen
sie haben gerade davon gesprochen es
gebe eine gefühlte inflation also ich
glaube dann sehen wir den menschen auf
der straße sprechen dass es keine
gefühlte inflation sagen die inflation
ist bei den menschen angekommen und
deshalb müssen wir reagieren
wir haben eine inflation von 4,9 prozent
im januar 5,1 prozent im februar und 7,3
prozent im märz das ifo institut geht
davon aus dass wir vier fünf und sechs
prozent inflationsrate in diesem jahr
liegen werden das ist die höchste
inflation seit 40 jahren darum da ist es
die verdammte pflicht der regierung hier
zu reagieren da müssen sie nicht ständig
selber loben das eine
selbstverständlichkeit
also von daher sind wir grundsätzlich
froh dass es heute auf der tagesordnung
steht dass sie einem wurf gemacht haben
sie blasen denen jetzt hier ein bisschen
rhetorisch auf denn wenn wir uns das
wirklich angucken ist es etwas wenig was
da passiert ist und wir sind auch
überrascht herr minister am 16 februar
haben sie an dieser stelle bei der
befragung der bundesregierung gesagt man
könne freibeträge tarife nicht
unterjährig anpassen weil das zu viel
aufwand bedeuten würde für die
finanzverwaltung jetzt machen sie dass
das ist auch gut so sie haben
anscheinend an erkenntnisgewinn das ist
ja für minister gut dass er auch
erkenntnisse aufnimmt denn wir am damals
schon gesagt natürlich können wir den
tarif anpassen im laufenden jahr
natürlich können wir den grundfreibetrag
passen von da ist es gut dass wir jetzt
auf dem weg sind aber es ist noch zu
wenig meine damen und herren
denn das thema kalte progression haben
sie nach wie vor nicht aufgegriffen sie
erhöhen den grundfreibetrag wo man sich
die frage stellen kann um 363 euro auf
1010 1347 euro und laut
gesetzesbegründung das kann man auch
nachlesen unterstellen sie dabei eine
inflation für das jahr 2022 von drei
prozent diejenigen geschildert habe
legen wir bei fünf bis sechs prozent von
daher ist die maßnahme an sich richtig
aber nicht ausreichend meine damen und
herren von daher müssen noch mal eine
schippe drauflegen und
sie selber waren es jetzt noch als sie
noch in der opposition waren immer
gesagt habe der staat darf nicht von den
heimlichen steuererhöhungen profitieren
und jetzt haben sie die möglichkeit
darauf zu reagieren und meine bitte mit
bundesfinanzminister ist mit der ampel
koalition auch da die haben jetzt die
möglichkeit in der ampelkoalition darauf
zu reagieren und das wäre glaube ich gut
und von daher sollten sie dann auch
überlegen ob sie den progression bericht
nicht vorziehen darüber haben wir an der
befragung umfassend diskutiert damit wir
die kalte progression tatsächlich
absenken können dass wir die
tarifeckwerte anpassen können dass wir
das kindergeld anpassen können den
kinderfreibetrag anfragen sind sie
anpassen können sind sie haben hier
lediglich eine maßnahme rausgesucht und
in dem zusammenhang wäre es glaube ich
auch gut wenn wir gemeinsam nicht in
diesem gesetz alle drei enkel
koalitionäre haben das in ihrem
wahlprogramm drin stehen gehabt wir auch
über den einkommensteuertarif mal zu
diskutieren den mittelstandsbauch
abzubauen also daraus eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung zu machen weil das sehr
teuer sein wird dass wir gemeinsam dafür
eine lösung finden dass wir deshalb
tatsächlichen entlastung der mittleren
und unteren einkommen ihren deutschland
kommen können wir als union sind dabei
gerne mit vorschlägen und in der
diskussion und tragen das dann auch
gerne mit meine damen und herren dann
haben sie herausgestellt dass der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag um 20 prozent
auf 1200 euro erhöht
das kann man begrüßen insbesondere wenn
man dadurch einen vorteil hat sie haben
aber in ihrer rede auch ausgeführt der
bundesfinanzminister dass sie nur
zielgerichtete maßnahmen
angehen wollen die einfache erhöhung des
pauschbetrages ist keine zielgerichtete
maßnahmen der bundesverband der
lohnsteuerhilfevereine hat in seiner
stellungnahme geschrieben von der
anhebung profitieren jedoch
hauptsächlich arbeitnehmer die überhaupt
keine oder nur geringe beruflich
veranlasste aufwendungen haben sowie
diejenigen deren aufwendungen vom
arbeitgeber erstattet werden dafür geben
sie eine million handy milliarde aus
ohne dass es zielgerichtet ist es gibt
andere dinge die wir wichtiger machen
wir sind die zielgerichtet gemacht
werden könnten von daher ist das glaube
ich auch ein eher eine
werbeveranstaltung bei dem
werbungskostenpauschbetrag die sie hier
durch für meine damen und herren und
dann zur entfernungspauschale
da sage ich selbstkritisch auch wir
haben von den 38 cent gesprochen glaube
ich auch in einer situation als noch
nicht unbedingt erkennbar war wie die
spritpreise steigen das ist eine da ist
wo entfernungskilometer sind es 13 das
ist fünf gefahrenen kilometer 1,5 cent
wenn ich mir angucke dass ein
durchschnittliches wenn ich jetzt ein
diesel nehme wenn man die noch fahren
darf haben sie sieben liter verbrauch
auf 100 kilometer wenn sie 80 cent
steigerung unterstellen dann sind sie
pro gefahrenen kilometer 1 bei einer
zusätzlichen belastung die er bei 5 bis
6 cent liegt und sie erhöhen rund drei
cent und es geht nur um ein
werbungskostenabzug das ist zu weniger
minister hier müssen wir noch gemeinsam
eine schippe drauflegen damit wir
tatsächlich zu einer entlastung kommen
und ein genereller fehler
ist an dem wir auch mitgewirkt haben ich
finde das kann man auch ich sagen dass
wir zwei klassen gesellschaft bei den
pendlern haben ich glaube es ist nicht
mehr zu rechtfertigen dass wir die
erhöhte entfernungspauschale haben ab
dem 21 1 kilometer jeder kilometer muss
die höhere entfernungspauschale haben
das sollten wir
diesen gesetzgebungsvorhaben vielleicht
auch noch mal angehen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
viel gebe es noch zu sagen ich hätte
auch gerne was zu unserem antrag gesagt
den wir parallel eingebracht habe aber
wir haben ja heute noch die gelegenheit
zum corona steuer hilfe gesetz diese
debatte zu führen und der kollege dörr
wenn sie so eine angriffsfläche bieten
dann muss ich mich erst mal an ihm
abarbeiten bevor ich unseren guten
antrag darstellen aber sie haben ja die
möglichkeit im rahmen der
gesetzesberatung diesen antrag weiter zu
verbessern in den gesetzentwurf weiter
zu verbessern wir als union als
konstruktive opposition stehen gerne zur
seite und helfen ihnen dabei einen
vernünftigen gesetzentwurf das gesetz
daraus zu machen herzlichen dank
fritz künstler war das aus der
unionsfraktion und werden die momente in
der unionsfraktion von konstruktive
opposition geredet wird dann löst das
reaktionen aus in der koalition haben
wir eben auch gemerkt der bundestag
diskutiert
erstmals über das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 und der
nächste redner zu diesem punkt ist
michael schrodi finanzpolitischer
sprecher der spd fraktion
präsidenten meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren herr künstler opposition ist
mist das wissen aber deswegen muss doch
das politische leben eines
oppositionspolitikers
nicht daraus bestehen ein sammelsurium
nur anforderungen zu stellen die sich
übrigens nicht mal in dem antrag
teilweise wieder finden diese vorgelegt
haben und die keine wirklich gezielten
maßnahmen für die aktuelle situation
darstellen konstruktive
oppositionspolitik müssen sie wahrlich
noch
die haben wir mit allen auswirkungen
umsätzen 100 zusätzlichen steigen die
preise und teuerungsrate haben
zahlreiche bürgerinnen und bürger stark
belastet die grenzen ihrer finanziellen
belastbarkeit
auch sie gebracht wir wollen in dieser
schwierigen situation
für verhältnisse sorgen in dem alle
menschen gut zurecht kommen können die
ampelkoalition hat deshalb umfangreiche
maßnahmen beschlossen die wir jetzt
umsetzen werden die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage gehört dazu denn und
verdoppelte heizkostenzuschuss und eben
auch in einem gesamtpaket dieses
steuerentlastungsgesetz mit drei kernen
maßnahmen die wir hier beschließen
werden die erhöhung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags um 200 euro
rückwirkend zum ersten januar 2022
damit reduzieren wir das zu versteuernde
einkommen eine gute maßnahme sehr
geehrten damen und herren zweitens die
nach der anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler was
haben sie vor einem monat noch gefolgt
gesagt das sei ein großer wurf wir
machen das jetzt weil wir wissen dass es
natürlich eine höhere belastung auch für
pendlerinnen und pendler gibt auf die
wir reagieren übrigens davon profitieren
gibt es auch geringverdiener den damit
erhöht sich auch die mobilitäts prämie
die diejenigen bekommen die arbeiten
aber nun kleines gehalt beziehen die
teile steuern zahlen das ist glaube ich
eine richtige maßnahme und ganzen zahlt
ist die anhebung des grundfreibetrags um
363 euro auf 10.000 347 euro ebenfalls
rückwirkend zum ersten januar das heißt
ganz konkret der teil des geheilt für
saas gehalts auf den keine steuern
anfallen vergrößert sich es bleibt mehr
im geldbeutel und wir gleichen damit das
hat der herr bundesfinanzminister
richtig gesagt auf die wirkung der
kalten progression gerade für kleinere
mittlere einkommen aus und zwar so dass
alle einkommen steuerpflichtigen
gleichermaßen entlastet werden wobei man
dazusagen muss dass das relativ und
spürbar die entlastung für die bezieher
niedriger und mittlerer einkommen damit
auch höher und spürbarer ist und das ist
in der situation wo gerade diejenigen am
meisten betroffen sind von den
steigenden gaspreisen vor allen dingen
das richtige mittel der wahl dass wir
hier auf dem weg gehen weil es leider
unter allen
übrigen sind das 4,5 milliarden nur mit
diesem eingesetzt dass wir auf den weg
bringen es sind über 30 milliarden die
wir mit unseren paketen insgesamt auf
den weg bringen dann ein großes volumen
und wir haben da einen teil bereits
schon vor dem überfall russlands auf die
ukraine auf den weg gebracht danach
hatte die situation noch einmal
verschärfte werden deshalb zusätzlich
weitere maß damit zu den aktuellen
hinzufügen die finanzierung die
finanzielle unterstützung für die
bürgerinnen bürger weitere auf den weg
bringen wie beispielsweise die
energiepreis pauschale in höhe von 300
euro als zuschuss zum gehalt gerade das
hilft auch kleinen und mittleren
einkommen zu bekommen dieses geld direkt
genauso wie der familienzuschuss als
einmal bonus ergänzend zum kindergeldes
kenntnisse aus der pandemie als
kinderbonus auch da gilt die
geringverdiener die kleinen auf die
grundsicherung wird es nicht angerechnet
mit dem freibetrag aber wird es gerade
für höchste einkommen verrechnet das
heißt es kommt unten an und diejenigen
die ganz oben sie mit einkommen bekommen
es nicht ich will das gerächt weil es
wieder eine gezielte maßnahme ist für
die menschen in diesem land das heißt
wir wollen dass alle menschen gut
zurechtkommen mit einem großen paket und
das eben gezielt ist das sozial
ausgewogen ist dass die adressiert die
am meisten diese mittel auch benötigen
und sie von der cdu/csu
aufgestanden muss man sich über den
antrag in zweierlei hinsicht einfach nur
wundern es ist erstens keine einzige
maßnahme herr dobrindt in diesen zwölf
geeigneter irgendwie neu
die kleine mittlere einkommen wirklich
substanziell zu entlasten kein einziges
auf die aktuelle situation abgestimmt
das instrument einziger zuschuss keine
einzige wirkliche leistungserhöhung was
sie und das bundesland nrw und bayern
dafür fordern ist neben der anhebung des
grundfreibetrags auch jetzt eine
anhebung der act werke des
einkommenssteuertarifs
voran zu bringen was zusätzliche fünf
milliarden kosten würde und was sie
genau wissen vor allem höhere höchste
einkommen entlasten würden dass es in
dieser situation nicht das richtige
mittel der wahl meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren und zum zweiten muss
man sich darüber wundern warum sie hier
zu diesem gesetzentwurf herr kollege
dobrindt in einem antrag dinge fordern
die vornehmlich fragen der
unternehmensbesteuerung betreffen und
die wir in der übernächsten
tagesordnungspunkt mit dem vierten
kroner steuer hilfe gesetz auf den weg
bringen ich nenne hier exemplarisch
verbesserte abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
fragen des verlust vor einem rücktritt
oder die verringerung
erklärungen der abgabefrist für
steuerentlastungen es sind alles
maßnahmen die sich hier in ihrem antrag
finden der eigentlich ganz andere dinge
adressieren soll und die wir jetzt in
gut einer stunde auf den weg bringen
werden dass apple koalition sie sollten
bitteschön alle anträge lesen und ihre
anträge dann so ausformulieren das
natürlich passend für diesen
tagesordnungspunkt dass da sonst eine
glatte themaverfehlung hier an meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
werden unser ziel alle bürgerinnen und
bürger gezielt zu entlasten auch mit
diesen
steuerentlastungsgesetz nun voranbringen
wir wollen die bürgerinnen bürger
spürbar entlasten die gestiegenen preise
die teuerungsraten abdämpfen und da ist
die opposition herzlich eingeladen sich
konstruktiv an dieser debatte weiterhin
zu beteiligen darauf freue mich dann
auch gerne seinem ausschuss vielen dank
michael show die der finanzpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion in der ersten
beratung des bundestages zum
steuerentlastungsgesetz 2022 es geht um
die anhebung des grundfreibetrags es
geht um die anhebung von pauschbeträgen
und es geht um die anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler und
das geht um den nächsten redner und das
ist kein gottschalk der finanzpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen vor allen dingen an
dieser stelle verehrte bürger und
steuerzahler
heute sprechen wir in erster lesung über
das so genannte
steuerentlastungsgesetz man lieber ampel
männchen und weibchen selbstverständlich
auch wir müssen sehr dass sie langsam in
der realität ankommen und entlastung für
bürger auf den weg bringen aufgrund der
inflation das fordern wir als fdp schon
sehr lange daran sich standhaft
geweigert aber wir sollten bei der
wahrheit bleiben eine der maßnahmen die
sie hier als entlastung an kreisen
nämlich die erhöhung des
grundfreibetrages war und ist nichts
anderes als die freistellung des
einkommens steuerliche existenzminimum
geld also was sie den bürger mit ihrer
verfehlten energiepolitik und
steuerpolitik vorher genommen haben
meine damen und herren ich
möchte sie an dieser stelle in aller
deutlichkeit daran erinnern und das
haben wir ja auch gestern und im letzten
tagen gesehen dass es mit der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und gesetzen nicht
so haben jetzt zieht ihre mit erlaubnis
der präsident und im beschluss des
zweiten senates vom november 1998
unseres verfassungsgericht ist was sie
hoffentlich noch achten heißt es das
einst kommen steuerliche existenzminimum
ist für alle steuerpflichtigen
unabhängig von ihren individuellen
grenzsteuersatz in voller höhe von der
einkommen steuerfrei zu stellen was sie
hier also tun ist gesetz und
rechtsstaatlichkeit und keine entlastung
der bürger sie geben ihnen das zurück
was sie ihnen durch ihre inflation
genommen haben meine damen und herren
und hände hier schon beim
grundfreibetrag sind sie stellen im
gesetzentwurf für eine berechnung an die
sie auf ihren wert von 10.000 347 euro
kommen sind mich drei prozent der
kollege künstler hat es gesagt und sie
nehmen diese entlastung vor bei einer
inflationsrate von mittlerweile 74
prozent an wissen wir heute zusammen
gefasst dass sie etwas was sie tun
müssen entlastungen nennen und diese
entlastung sehenden auges viel zu gering
ist und sie nicht mal den leitsatz des
bundesverfassungsgerichts erfüllen meine
damen und herren das ist nicht mal
rechtsbruch
und gut gedacht ist nicht immer gut
gemacht das trifft vor allem für
sozialdemokraten zu wir werden bei
dieser frage noch mal einen
änderungsantrag einbringen nachbessern
sie müssen hier deutlich erhöhen wir
werden einen vorschlag von mindestens 12
1600 euro hier ins spiel bringen und
ähnliches meine damen und herren gilt
für die vorgezogene erhöhung der
entfernungspauschale
die spritpreise haben sich im vergleich
teilweise um 70 cent und mehr erhöht das
kann man übrigens gut gerade aber ich
glaube das ist die ideologische fein
schrift das tun sie nicht beim adac
nachlesen wir reden ja also vom
preissteigerung von knapp 50 prozent
und dafür wird eine entfernungs
kostenpauschale die bürgerinnen und
bürger tun sie sich das an um nicht mal
ein zehntel und zwar ab dem 21 kilometer
erhöht das ist etikettenschwindel da
sage ich tue was sie für die menschen
über haben die pendeln und jeden tag auf
ihrer maroden infrastruktur sich zur
arbeit fehlen meine damen und herren
und zu guter letzt ich kann es mir nicht
ersparen ich finde es schön fritz
güntzler liebe union sie sind in der
opposition angekommen herrlich
herzlichen glückwunsch ich persönlich
kann nämlich ihrem antrag viel
abgewinnen sie wissen auch warum
insbesondere beim punkt 5 musste ich
tatsächlich schmunzeln beim thema kalte
progression nähern wir uns offenbar
nämlich an also schön das ist endlich
einsehen insbesondere mit dem tarif auf
rädern in dem wir auch wieder bringen
bis die da entsprechend hoffentlich
reagieren dass sie da jetzt tatsächlich
wie gestern auch langsam auf der linie
kommen herzlichen glückwunsch liebe
union
aber um dauerhaft gegen unerwartet hohe
inflation etwas tun zu können sollten
wir eben nicht nur die tarifeckwerte der
einkommensteuer endlich indexiert wir
werden auch vorschlagen in den nächsten
wochen entsprechend automatische
anpassung der inflation vorzunehmen denn
sie können es nicht meine damen und
herren von der ampel freibeträge
freigrenze und pauschbeträge sei es eben
gesagt jahre handy elf jahre da waren
sie übrigens auch mal in der regierung
sind dann auch berechtigt rausgeflogen
prognostizieren auch bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl auch hier eine
automatische indexierung vorzunehmen
meine damen und herren und zu guter
letzt nordosten war anwesend ist sie
haben gesagt die paris erklärte
anpassung und der tarif auf rädern das
würde nicht gehen spinning auf ich
empfehle da eine sehr gute mathematische
abhandlung das können vielleicht noch
einige im hause eine simulation von hans
georg peter sind der zum fazit kommt
eine gerechte entlastung wird und ist
nur zu garantieren wenn man entsprechend
eine systematische index bindung vorn
und meine damen und herren wir werden
sie kritisch und fair begleiten durch
die beratung wir freuen uns drauf
insbesondere war die cdu ich kann mich
nur wiederholen in der opposition
angekommen ist herzlichen glück und dank
gottschald gottschalk pardon für die spd
fraktion in der ersten beratung des
steuerentlastungsgesetzes 20 22 und da
steht schon bereit der nächste redner
wer kommt aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen ist sascha müller und
sascha müller ist ob man eben
finanzausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
heute diskutiert wird die politischen
antworten auf die hohen energiepreise
und damit im besonderen die steuerlichen
maßnahmen aus dem ersten entlastungs
paket der koalition
wahrscheinlich geht es ja uns allen nach
wie vor so wir sehen mit großer sorge
und entsetzen die ukrainische städte
bombardiert wohnhäuser und kliniken
beschossen werden mit jedem tag des
krieges 6 die note für die menschen in
der ukraine
ich denke das relativiert auch manche
auseinandersetzung die wir hier haben
als die ampel sich im februar auf das
erste entlastungs paket geeinigt hatte
spürten wir noch die hoffnung dass den
menschen der ukraine ein krieg erspart
bliebe und wir hoffen auch dass
steigende energiepreise und die damit
ausgelöste fossil getrieben inflation
nur eine temporäre erscheinung werden
könnten nun einen tag nach der
vorstellung des entlastungspaket das hat
er sich diese hoffnung auf grausamste
weise zerschlagen schnell war klar dass
wir ein zweites entlastungs paket
schnüren müssen auch dass sich die
koalition dann am 24 märz darauf
geeinigt hat mir ist wichtig zu betonen
dass beide entlastungspaket eine ganze
reihe von sehr gut aufeinander
abgestimmten maßnahmen beinhalten es
sind maßnahmen darunter für die breite
der gesellschaft aber insbesondere für
jene die es ganz besonders hart trifft
weil sie fast die fossil betriebene
inflation die gestiegenen energiepreise
nicht so einfach wegstecken können das
unterstreiche
das deshalb weil die einzelnen maßnahmen
nicht isoliert sondern kontext mit den
anderen maßnahmen gesehen werden müssen
wie zb die frühere abschaffung der eeg
umlage oder dem heizkostenzuschuss
hier und heute geht es also um die
steuerlichen aspekte und dabei um drei
maßnahmen aus dem ersten paket vom
februar der grundfreibetrag wird erhöht
der arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag ebenso wie
die pendlerpauschale wird angehoben die
anhebung des grundfreibetrags um 363
euro auf 10.000 347 euro rückwirkend zum
jahresbeginn gehört zu den maßnahmen die
die ganze breite der gesellschaft
denn sie kommt allen einkommen
steuerzahlerin einkommensteuerzahler
zugute die zweite maßnahme betrifft die
anhebung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags
auch dies eine erleichterung und sie
bedeutet gleichzeitig eine erhebliche
steuervereinfachung mehr
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
können so auf das lange rechnet von
arbeitswegen und das sammeln von belegen
für ihre werbungskosten verzichten weil
dies von der höheren pauschale abgedeckt
ist und
zur dritten maßnahme ja die vorgezogene
aber weiter befristete anhebung der
pendlerpauschale ab dem 21 kilometer
zugegeben da hätten wir uns in der
fraktion auch andere wege vorstellen
können aber natürlich sehen wir die
erhöhte belastung für pendlerinnen und
pendler insbesondere für diejenigen die
keine alternative zum auto haben aber
die wirkung der pendlerpauschale bleibt
noch mal unter ökologischen
gesichtspunkten diskutabel und aspekten
der verteilungsgerechtigkeit auch
vielleicht kontraproduktiv wohlhabender
profitieren sehr viel mehr als arme wer
sich ein größeres auto leisten kann und
dann vielleicht einen großen suv fährt
erhält eine größere steuerentlastung als
diejenigen die sich nur den kleinen
wagen mit deutlich geringerem ausstoß
leisten können um so mehr froh bin ich
darüber dass wir in der koalition
zusammen mit spd und fdp vereinbart
haben die pendlerpauschale noch in
dieser legislatur ökologisch und sozial
neu auszurichten hier liegen bereits
interessante konzepte auf dem tisch wir
werden das auf die agenda setzen
mit dem energie geld was sie an zweiten
entlastungspaket mit der energiepreis
pauschale bereits ein stück weit
vorwegnehmen dass eine ökologische
soziale sinnvoller maßnahme bereits in
arbeit und liebe freuen kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union hier vorliegende
antrag
gibt mir die gelegenheit zu einer
grundsätzlichen bemerkungen
meine fraktion war ja in der
vergangenheit lange für meinen geschmack
zu lange in der opposition 100 sich
dabei konstruktiv kritisch im bundestag
mit eigenen vorschlägen ein gibt auch
das etwas was ich von der größten
oppositionsfraktion derzeit noch zur
seltene höhere der vorliegende antrag
der union berlin hatte in der tat eine
reihe von eigenen forderungen ist dann
würde somit schon mal ein kleiner
fortschritt es gab in meiner fraktion in
der oppositionsarbeit aber noch eine
andere maxime er dem ich auch als damals
noch nicht parlament aber gefreut hat
dich immer richtig fand fordern
opposition nichts was du nicht in der
regierung selbst umsetzen würde ist das
auch eine frage von glaubwürdigkeit und
das wird nichts mit dem vorigen antrag
noch nicht gegeben denn ganz ehrlich
liebe union sind sie wirklich sicher
dass sie diesen forderungskatalog auch
angegangen umgesetzt hätten wenn sie
noch in der regierung werden in dieser
schwierigen zeit wirklich ich habe da
meine zweifel
ich weiß nicht ob die lange liste die
uns kollege otto fricke zum aus ändert
der haushaltsberatung letzten
sitzungswoche so eindrucksvoll
präsentiert hat mit diesem antrag noch
länger geworden ist aber glauben sie
meinen sie es wirklich ernst dass sie
hier ein paket schnüren können in dieser
situation mit noch so viel unbekannt für
unsere zukunft das einfach mal die
gießkanne auspacken kränzler weite
zielgerichtet ist um bund länder und
kommunen viele weitere milliarden kosten
würde diese milliarden machen wir lieber
für die kommenden jahr wirklich
schwierigen aufgaben und
es ist eben jetzt nicht die zeit für die
grosse gießkanne auszupacken oder werden
müssen da helfen wo es am meisten brennt
bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern und eben
auch und da werden wir wenn es wenn es
nötig ist auch handeln auch bei den
unternehmen ich möchte zum schluss noch
die gelegenheit nutzen auf ein wort
hinzuweisen dass der csu-vorsitzende
beispiel ministerpräsident markus söder
seit dem sonntag versucht etablieren der
markt das bild einen angeblichen
hyperinflation angewandt der begriff
nicht bewusst gewählt nicht aussagen
wird sogar zu emotionalisieren
auch wenn wir über die frage die welche
reagieren in diesem wohnhaus kontrovers
diskutieren sollten wir alle die in
verantwortung stehen es vermeiden in
diesen uns alle herausforderungen zeiten
ängste zu schüren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union wenn sich ihren
einfluss haben dann reden sie bitte mit
markus söder darüber ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
sascha müller für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen und damit für die ampel
koalition insgesamt denn die legt diesen
gesetzentwurf über den ihr seit kurz
nach neuen diskutiert wird vor
und geht es jetzt weiter mit einer
sogenannten koinzidenz sehen die zwei
redner die sich jetzt gleich
hintereinander hören die haben sie heute
morgen auch bei uns schon sehen und
hören können das beginnt christian görke
für die linksfraktion
steigt die inflation nicht nur die
gefühlte und entwertet meine damen und
herren ihre entlassungspapiere von der
koalition besonders ihr erstes
entlastungspaket ist ja nun wirklich
nicht ziehen oder studi nehmen wir mal
die erhöhung der pendlerpauschale
abgesehen davon dass bei ihren plänen
weiterhin viele pendler trotz höheren
pauschbetrag ist so gut wie leer
ausgehen profitieren vor allem die und
das wissen sie die die viel fahren ja
aber auch die die hohe einkommen
versteuern können und meine damen und
herren von den 300.000 die in
brandenburg pendeln fallen bei ihren
plänen ein drittel durch das raster
meine damen und herren der koalition sie
sagen ja immer sie sind ja die
fortschritts koalition und könnten ja an
und werden jetzt an so vielen
stellschrauben also richtig drehen wäre
schön wenn sie an den richtigen drehen
und richtige präzise vorschläge machen
wie bse drin mit dem einstieg in ein
mobilitäts geld um eine faire und vor
allen dingen verbrauch gerechte
entlastung unabhängig vom einkommen zu
schaffen insofern hätte ich gerade von
den grünen aber von den user oder den
linken in der spd erwartet als vor
einigen tagen die tür für diese
diskussion aufging dass sie sich für
eine reform der pendlerpauschale
eingesetzt hätten und dass wir dann auch
ein mobilitäts geld bekommen ja haben
wir gesehen ergebnis liegt auf dem tisch
und wenn denn selbst heute meine damen
und herren selbst die cdu schon von
einem mobilitäts geld träumen ja das
muss ihnen doch zu denken geben aber
anscheinend gilt ja in der ampel das
motto wenn wir entlasten denn dann
lassen wir mal die spitzeneinkommen
gleich mal mit wissen sie was das ist es
fdp-politik eins zu eins so weit zum
fortschritt dieser position in der
studie aber mal ehrlich zur energiepreis
pauschale einmalig 300 euro brutto netto
beträge kennen sie sicherlich selbst ist
müsste ihnen aufgefallen sein dass bei
diesen bei diesen
inflationsentwicklungen
die entwicklungen doch regelrecht
verpuffen und meine damen und lese ich
nicht auflegen sich nicht auf und dass
sie dass sie als sozialdemokraten bei
diesem entlastungspaket auch nur auf die
erwerbstätigen setzen und die
rentnerinnen und rentner millionen von
rentnerinnen und rentner einfach nicht
berücksichtigt haben macht nicht nur
nicht fassungslos sondern die
wohlfahrtsverbände und
andro
und wissen sie diese rentnerinnen und
rentner haben jahre lang malocht und ich
kann mich noch entsinnen da haben sie
vor sechs monaten
den respekt eingeforderte sogar
plakatiert es wäre an der zeit dass sie
jetzt noch umkehren und im
parlamentarischen prozess diesmal bei
revidieren das erwarten nicht nur vier
von ihnen meine damen und herren
zur energie steuer die senkung war
richtig angesichts dieser preis
explosion aber wenn die logistiker die
taxiunternehmen die 4000 unternehmen
nicht pleite gehen soll muss die
steuersenkung länger als drei monate
laufen es braucht jetzt verlässliche
lösung keine wunderkerzen die schon nach
drei monaten abgefackelt sind und ich
bin
auch nicht prophezeite ihm schon jetzt
dass sie auf unsere vorschläge wieder
zurückkommen wollen die eine verlegung
dieser maßnahmen mindestens auf sechs
monate zum inhalt haben und erzählen sie
mir bitte nicht etwas vom geld wer
schafft bei der bundeswehr an der
schuldenbremse verbreite zug lassen er
schafft auch eine finanzierung für eine
sozial ausgewogene leistung der bürger
mitbürger hinzubekommen vielen dank
sagt christian görke der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion und dem vorplatz der
finanzpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion markus herbrand und wenn sie um
viertel vor neun schon bei uns gewesen
sind haben sie ein wenig von seinen
positionen auch schon mitbekommen können
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
nichts zu tun ist in dieser lage keine
option das hat der bundesfinanzminister
eben gesagt und dafür danke ich ihnen
ganz herzlich
denn mit diesem steuerentlastungsgesetz
22 hat die ampel fortschritts koalition
ungewöhnlich schnell verantwortung im
bereich der finanz und steuerpolitik für
unser land übernommen
wir
geben mit diesem entlastungspaket eine
antwort auf eine andauernde krise denn
die ursache für dieses entlastungspaket
sind nicht die auswirkungen des krieges
sondern die auch von experten in der
höhe und der dauer nicht angenommene
inflation in deutschland und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen politik vermag
weder für eine niedrige inflation zu
sorgen noch kann sie alles ausgleichen
was zu einer
teuerungsrate führt aber was sie zu
leisten imstande ist das macht die ampel
hier wir setzen ein zeichen die
bürgerinnen und bürger können sich auf
diese regierung verlassen wir lassen
niemanden allein
herr kollege herr brandt starten wir
eine zwischenbemerkungen dazwischen
frage von frau lötzsch aus der fraktion
die linke sie haben das wort fritsche
vielen dank herr kollege sie haben eben
den satz wiederholt den auch herr linder
gesagt hat der staat kann ich alles
ausgleichen die frage ist nur was ist
die alternative
ich finde an dieser stelle wäre es doch
nötig den unternehmen zusagen bezahlt
euro leute anständig damit der staat ist
eben nicht ausgleichen muss und sie
haben ja beispiele von unternehmen die
in zb in ballungsgebieten einen zuschuss
zahlen für die mobilität oder 1 für die
mietkosten wäre das nicht die richtige
forderung die man stellen muss anstatt
zu sagen der staat kann ich alles
ausgleichen was ja so ein bisschen
suggeriert neue leute stellt euch auf
kürzung ein also die forderung
unterstützen sie die an die unternehmen
mitbezahlt eure leute anständig
es gibt es gehört frau kollegin zur
wahrheit dazu dass der staat in einer
solchen hohen inflation lage nicht alles
wird ausgleichen können und wenn sie das
den menschen suggerieren dann ist das
falsch in meinen augen
wir entlasten die menschen mit der
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages werden
wir die steuer wirkungen der inflation
anpassen da hatte sich die alte
regierung ja deutlich verrechnet und
herr münster wenn sie uns jetzt hier
vorwerfen dass wir die kalte progression
nicht rechtzeitig ausgleichen dann ist
das ja schon
vorsichtig ausgedrückt witzig denn sie
hatten ja 16 jahre die zeit dass auch
rechtzeitig immer zu machen das haben
sie nicht gemacht und mit der
vorgezogenen
erhöhungs pauschale für fernpendler
versuchen wir einen ausgleich für
arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer
zu erreichen die längere strecken mit
dem auto zu ihrer arbeitsstätte
zurücklegen müssen das ist nämlich die
lebenswirklichkeit ganz vieler menschen
in diesem land und wir erhöhen die
arbeit den arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag bei
der einkommensteuer dauerhaft das ist
gleichzeitig entlastend wie auch
entbürokratisieren das ist auch eben
schon angesprochen worden und auch hier
muss man die berechnungen die eben
angenommen angenommen worden sind von
der union das muss man natürlich
zusammen sehen den arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag und die
entfernungspauschale das gehört zusammen
gedacht und wenn ich nicht wüsste dass
es besser wüssten herr günster würde es
dann heute noch annehmen dazu kommen
noch aus anderen gesetzen die
abschaffung der eeg umlage ab juli an
4000 kilowattstunden verbrauchen deshalb
bringt das eine entlastung von circa 180
euro eine dauerhafte abschaffung und der
heizkostenzuschuss für menschen mit
geringem einkommen sowie ein sofort
zuschlag für von armut
bedrohten kindern in höhe von 20 euro im
monat
meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen dieses gesamte
entlastungspaket hat insgesamt ein
volumen von circa 16 milliarden euro die
ampel hat hier sehr effektiv
wirtschaftlich vernünftig und vor allem
auch sozial ausgewogen gehandelt sie hat
damit ihre handlungsfähigkeit unter
beweis gestellt und diejenigen die jetzt
immer laut rufen das ist zu wenig zu
langsam zu bürokratisch die sollten ihre
eigenen leistungen in der vergangenheit
einmal kritisch hinterfragen danke
markus herbrand noch mal mit einer
anmerkung in richtung
unionsfraktion und aus der kommt auch
der nächste redner in dieser debatte in
der es um das steuerentlastungsgesetz
2022 geht um höhere grundfreibeträge um
höhere beträge und um eine anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler
nichts erreger wie gesagt aus der
unionsfraktion sebastian brehm csu
landesgruppe kolleginnen und kollegen
heute beraten hier in der ersten lesung
das sogenannte steuerentlastungsgesetz
2022 der ampel regierung es geht im
wesentlichen um die erhöhung des
grundfreibetrags um 363 euro die
anhebung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags
und 200 euro und die erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale um drei cent ab dem 21
kilometer das ist das erste paket der
ampel vor dem ukraine krieg was ist mit
dem zweiten paket was ist mit der
reduzierung des sprits was ist mit der
reduzierung der energie steuer auf den
sprit dieses paket wollen sie von den
grünen bereits schon wieder kassieren
herr kollege janitschek
hat er ein interview der augsburger
allgemeinen zeitung gegeben und hat
gesagt warum sollen wir benzin und
diesel bei diesem niveau noch teuer
subventionieren und hier gibt es in der
regierungskoalition wieder uneinigkeit
und die maßnahmen werden zunächst wieder
auf eis gelegt zu lasten der bürgerinnen
und bürger bei einer nicht gefühlten
sondern bestehenden rekord inflation und
extremen preissteigerungen in allen
bereichen und das ist ehrlich gesagt
völlig unzureichend denn die bürgerinnen
und bürger brauchen jetzt eine
entlastung und nicht erst in ein paar
monaten wenn sie sich vielleicht in der
regierungskoalition einigen können das
ist keine entlastungs politik sondern
chaos politik zu lasten der bürgerinnen
und bürger liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
zur sicherung der arbeitsplätze herr
kollege show die sie sagen sie machen
der weitreichende vorschläge zur
sicherung von arbeitsplätzen und
unternehmen die spielen in diesem gesetz
für die ampel übrigens keine rolle denn
für unternehmen gibt es keine
notwendigen entlastungen auch übrigens
in dem chor ohne starthilfe gesetz ist
es marginal auch die rasant steigenden
preise übrigens herr kollege schrodi
sind existenziell für die unternehmen
und für die arbeitsplätze in unserem
land und sie tun gar nichts liebe
kolleginnen kollegen von der ampel
was ist aus ihren versprechen geworden
herr lindner sie haben zahlreiche
anträge gestellt in der opposition im
wahlprogramm versprochen ich möchte nur
zwei dinge zitieren der staat profitiert
von rekord steuereinnahmen bei bürgern
kommt davon nichts an auch die
unternehmen warten bisher vergeblich auf
entlastungen und weiter beim
einkommensteuertarif wollen wir den
mittelstandsbauch vollständig abschaffen
heute steigt die steuerlast bei kleinen
und mittleren einkommen besonders
schnell von gehaltserhöhungen greift
sich der staat mehr als die hälfte das
ist leistungsfeindlich und ungerecht
ich kann das nur unterschreiben was in
ihrem wahlprogramm steht ich kann das
nur unterschreiben aber sie haben doch
die möglichkeit jetzt als finanzminister
das umzusetzen lieber kollege müller sie
haben gesagt man sollte in der
opposition nur das fordern was man
hinterher auch umsetzt dann frage ich
sie über rom setzten sie diese maßnahmen
jetzt nicht um
der grundfreibetrag steigt um 363 euro
das entspricht einer erhöhung von 6,2
prozent
der sachverständigenrat geht für dieses
jahr von einer inflation übrigens noch
vor märz und noch ohne ukraine krieg von
6,1 prozent aus deshalb reicht die
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages nicht aus
die kalte progression nur im ansatz zu
beseitigen und über kollege herr brand
wir haben das gemacht sie machen das
jetzt nicht die folge ihre politik ist
eine schmälerung der wirtschaftlichen
leistungsfähigkeit der steuerpflichtigen
die regierung nimmt wohlstandsverluste
einfach hin statt eine strategie für
neue perspektiven zu schaffen sowohl
wirtschaftsminister habe ich als auch
finanzminister linden nehmen dieses hin
und sagen das auch noch öffentlich
sie nehmen einfach das zur kenntnis dass
die menschen ärmer werden und sie tun
nichts dagegen was sie heute vorschlagen
die mit kolleginnen kollegen ist ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein
wir brauchen wir brauchen zumindest
einen vollständigen ausgleich der
auswirkungen der kalten progression und
eine deutliche verschiebung der
steuerkurve nach rechts und zur
pendlerpauschale vielleicht noch
abschließend zur pendlerpauschale
abschließend noch 80 prozent der
berufspendler sind laut statistischem
bundesamt weniger als 25 kilometer zu
ihrer arbeitsstätte unterwegs wenn wir
das ganze einmal großzügig durchrechnen
übrigens schwache leistung ist es was
sie hier vorschlagen das ist eine
schwache leistung lieber kollege story
nichts anderes ihr gesetz ist eine
schwache leistung
wenn wir die pendlerpauschale und ihre
erhöhung einmal großzügig durchrechnen
dann ist für 80 prozent der pendler
macht das 10 euro im jahr aus das reicht
nicht einmal für eine tankfüllung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen machen sie doch
wenigstens die pendlerpauschale ab dem
ersten kilometer höher das wäre richtig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt
keine strategie der bundesregierung
gegen inflation es gibt keine strategie
der bundesregierung gegen steigende
energiepreise und es gibt keine
strategie der bundesregierung gegen
steigende lebensmittelpreise die
regierung darauf die verluste der bürger
doch nicht einfach nur verbuchen sie
muss sie verhindern liebe kolleginnen
kollegen deswegen tun sie was und
bessern sie in diesem gesetz nach ich
danke herzlich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
so was gern bremen für die unions
fraktion im finanzausschuss
und auch der nächste redner ist mitglied
im finanzausschuss carlos kasper wetter
seien aus der spd-fraktion und es geht
nach wie vor um das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
stehen derzeit vor großen
herausforderungen
die gestiegenen energiekosten belasten
uns alle vor allem aber treffen sie
kleine und mittlere einkommen ich
vertrete das chemnitzer umland ihren
bundestag das ist eine eher ländlich
geprägte region es gibt viele
kleinstädte und dörfer der öpnv ist
nicht gut ausgebaut und die menschen
sind auf ihr auto angewiesen
das gilt insbesondere für diejenigen die
in schichten arbeiten und zum beispiel
nachts ist in das vw werk nach mosel
pendeln müssen oder zur frühschicht in
das krankenhaus nach liechtenstein aber
gerade zu diesen zeiten gibt es eben
keine busse und bahnen die fragen
viele frauen schlichtweg ihr auto und
sie zur arbeit kommen wollen das
chemnitzer umland aber auch ganz sachsen
ist leider auch eine region mit sehr
niedrigen löhnen beispielsweise wird
fast die hälfte der im erzgebirge
beschäftigten menschen von der
mindestlohn erhöhung im november
profitieren aber wie soll jemand da noch
nicht mal zwölf euro pro stunde verdient
jetzt auch noch die gestiegenen sprit
und heizkosten stemmen sie können es
sich schlichtweg nicht leisten noch mehr
geld für sprit heizkosten und
nahrungsmittel auszugehen und deswegen
auch mir jetzt und heute entlastung
mit dem steuerentlastungspaket setzen
wir genau da an wir bringen einen ganzen
strauß voller maßnahmen auf den weg die
direkt bei den menschen ankommt und die
direkt wirken wir werden die energie
steuern auf diesel und benzin
vorübergehend auch unbefristet
ganz konkret heißt das auf benzin wird
30 cent billiger und diese 14 cent das
kommt allen zugute nicht nur den
abhängig beschäftigten sondern auch den
kleinen und mittleren betrieben die auf
ihr auto angewiesen sind und zb
auf mit dem auto zur arbeit fahren
müssen der ambulante pflegedienst oder
den klar der kleine handwerksbetrieb von
nebenan
bei dieser vorübergehenden steuersenkung
ist mir eins aber ganz besonders wichtig
wir müssen die konzerne dazu
verpflichten diese steuersenkung direkt
weiterzugeben die preise müssen an der
zapfsäule sinken und auch kein teil darf
sich wiederholen was wir in den
vergangenen wochen gesehen haben
raffinerien haben die spritpreise
überdurchschnittlich getrieben und damit
unverschämter gewinne gemacht und
ich bin mir sicher dass insbesondere
auch das finanzministerium
auf die weitergabe der senkung achtet
sehr geehrte damen und herren eine
weitere maßnahme die wir auf den weg
bringen ist die erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale der mehr als 21
kilometer zur arbeit fährt kann künftig
38 38 cent pro kilometer über die
steuererklärung abrechnen diese regelung
wird rückwirkend am ersten januar gelten
und befristet sein bis 2026 auch wie
hier haben wir die menschen im
ländlichen raum im blick aber es sind
nicht nur die gestiegenen spritpreise
die uns vor großen herausforderungen
stellen auch die heizkosten explodieren
derzeit deswegen bringen wir ein
weiteres wirklich sehr wichtiges
instrument auf den weg jede
arbeitnehmerin jeder selbstständige
erhält 300 euro als direktzahlung zum
ausgleich auf die hohen heizkosten
dieses geld kommt schnell bei den
menschen an und das display auf jeden
lohnzettel bzw bei der
steuervorauszahlungen es ist nicht nur
schnell wirksam sondern auch sehr sozial
denn die 300 euro werden mit der
einkommenssteuer gegengerechnet wir
entlasten hier also insbesondere
geringverdienende die sowieso kaum
einkommensteuer zahlen
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
befinden uns in eine krise aber in der
krise liegt auch eine chance eine chance
langfristig die weichen für eine soziale
und nachhaltige zukunft zu stellen jetzt
ist der richtige moment um umfassend in
erneuerbaren energien zu investieren
jetzt ist der richtige moment um
wegzukommen von fossilen energieträgern
und jetzt ist der richtige moment und
den sozialstaat so auszurüsten dass
diejenigen mit kleinem geldbeutel diese
transformation mitgehen können
wir sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten sind bereit diesen
moment zu nutzen deswegen haben wir uns
stark gemacht für soziale instrumente
deswegen führen wir die direktzahlungen
1 und deswegen greifen wir
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher bei der
mit der befristeten energie
steuersenkung unter die arme wir schauen
gerade auch in den matchraum und den
lasten hier gezielt diejenigen die sich
schlichtweg mobilität nicht mehr leisten
können in meiner ersten rede hier im
bundestag habe ich gesagt wir machen
politik die wirkt an diesen entlastungs
paket sieht man dass sie wirkt und zwar
sozusagen gerecht
liebe kollegen könnten sie die
unterhaltung an der regierungsbank an
einer anderen stelle fortführen oder
gar nicht mehr auch gut
so da geht es um eine ermahnung bis tags
präsidentin für gespräche an der
regierungsbank und da weder christian
linder eben wir gesehen haben gleich
noch ein hinweis 13.30 werden wir ihn
mutmaßlich auch in diesem programm
wieder sehen gemeinsam mit robert habeck
denn es ist alles in allem große
entlastungs tag in anführungszeichen
heute offenbar hier wird über
steuerentlastung geredet später dann
noch mal aber die minister lindner und
harbeck wollen auch weitere hilfen für
die wirtschaft vorstellen dann um 13.30
wir haben erstmal dem abgeordneten klaus
stöber aus der fdp-fraktion ist es
mitglied im finanzausschuss
beleidigen sie eigentlich nicht nur bei
ihm sondern nur ihre eigenen liga
die pendlerpauschale kollegen künstler
und bremen haben schon angesprochen
warum eigentlich erst ab 21 kilometer
ich weiß nicht was letzte montag sie
können es ja mal probieren
tankstelle zu fahren so zu sagen ich
will mal für die ersten 20 liter weniger
bezahlen das für die reststrecke mal das
wird ein interessantes gespräch werden
und dann lächerliche drei cent ab dem 21
1 kilometer ich weiß nicht ob sie das
schon mal durchgerechnet haben ich habe
es für sie getan bei 30 kilometer
entfernung sind es 68 euro
werbungskosten mehr im jahr
steuererstattung gleichzeitig hat einer
mit 30 kilometer entfernung erfährt er
die doppelte strecke rund 1000 euro
mehrkosten durch spritzwasser 21 euro
entlastung stehen 1000 euro
mehrbelastung gegenüber das nennen sie
steuerentlastung
ministerin das ist kein sport
leistungsgesetz das ist kein aprilscherz
und kollegen der cdu ich habe mir hier
an ein paar angeschaut das sind viele
durchaus vernünftige vorschläge
enthalten aber gut zu lesen liegen
steuerlichen maßnahmen würde ich das
nicht nennen gut wäre es wenn sie sagen
worden die herzige steuergesetzgebung
ist komplett er vor mir bedürftig wir
haben 31 prozent steuersatz in
deutschland das heißt den höchsten der
ganzen welt wir haben die tatsache dass
jemand mit 58.000 euro einkommen bereits
den spitzensteuersatz bezahlt und das
bleibt so bis zu etwa 77.000 euro das
ist doch nicht gerecht ist noch keine
spitzenverdiener dass ingenieure ist ein
lehrer das sind gut verdienende
facharbeiter und kleine und mittlere
unternehmen keine spitzenverdiener die
58.000 euro einkommen haben und die
zahlen 42 prozent steuersatz sie haben
doch genügend fachleute in ihren partien
ihrer fraktionen um dieses problem
anzugreifen und sie tun es aber auch
nicht deswegen kann ich im netz
versprechen wir als fdp fraktionen
werden noch in diesem jahr ein
umfassendes gesetz zur steuerentlastung
vorlegen und dann liegt es an ihnen und
ich auch an kollegen lindner das dann
hier in der praxis umzusetzen vielen
dank
klaus stöber fw fraktion als zwei
minuten schneller fertig er hat sich ja
eigentlich angekündigt gewesen ist ich
kann sie verweisen meine damen herren
damen und herren auf das kleine bild das
sie ihr links sehen wir erwarten um 10
uhr die pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach mit rk ii präsident wieder
und mit gernot mark präsidenten der
deutschen interdisziplinären vereinigung
für intensiv und notfallmedizin geben
wir live drauf das programm des
bundestages werden wir ihn weitere
ausstrahlen über unsere youtube und
facebook kanäle und bis es soweit ist
hören wir auch auf diese maus spiel weg
noch mal rein in lisa paus wollte ich
sagen stimmt aber gar nicht denn sie
sehen bewegungen in der
bundespressekonferenz die angekündigten
protagonisten sind auf dem weg zu ihren
plätzen ich vermute mal dass das bild
über kurz oder lang dann auch größer
sein wird und sie die bereits
angesprochenen
herren in diesem fall dann auch sehen
werden und diese pressekonferenz dann
auch beginnt so dass sich an dieser
stelle jetzt abgeben die die
bundespressekonferenz nicht unweit des
reichstagsgebäudes und wie gesagt alle
gehe die debatte weiter verfolgen wollen
denen lege ich unserem youtube und
facebook kanal ans herz
[Applaus]
freizustellen der inflation zu begegnen
und wir erhöhen auch den arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag und wir ändern auch was bei
der pendlerpauschale
dieses gesetz ist nur ein teil des
gesamten paketes was bereits beschlossen
ist von der bundesregierung es kommt
noch die sozial gerechte energiepreis
pauschale es konnten auch einen
familienbonus wir schaffen die eeg
umlage ab wir haben bereits die
heizkostenpauschale
erhöht und auf weitere teile werden
folgen wichtig ist in diesem
zusammenhang natürlich auch jenseits
dieser steuerlichen finanziellen dinge
dass wir so schnell wie möglich raus
kommen aus der abhängigkeit von
russischem öl von erdgas und von kohle
aus russland meine damen tja und
das machen wir auch mit vielerlei
instrumenten ein bitterer punkt ist dass
wir eben nicht vollständig sofort raus
können dass wir in gewisser weise eine
shoppen diversifizierung jetzt betreiben
ein zweiter wichtiger punkt ist aber
dass wir beim thema energieeffizienz
jetzt wirklich den turbo anlegen und das
haben wir auch mit dem zweiten
steuerentlastungspaket nochmal verankert
der verbrauch von energie der muss auch
deutlich sinken wir können das mich
alles über preis und exponierung machen
meine damen und herren und deswegen
helfen wir auf jeden bürgerinnen und
bürgern in dem wir eben auch einfach und
maßnahmen wie zum beispiel den
hydraulischen abgleich der heizung ja
dass wir das unterstützen dass wir
heizungs austausch zusätzlich
unterstützen das auch so dinge wie
thermostate auswechseln man kann mit
kleinen dingen schon richtig was leisten
jede kilowattstunde die eingespart wird
die ist wirklich wichtig und dafür haben
wir den sommer zeit und dann auch im
winter besser dazustehen auch hier
unterstützt die regierung
und
das große paket das sogenannte ist auf
den weg gebracht das heißt wir machen
aber auch eine deutliche beschleunigung
im bereich des ausbaus der erneuerbaren
energien so werden wir unabhängig von
russland so werden wir aber auch
unabhängig von fossiler inflation und
das thema hatten wir leider auch schon
vor dem ukraine kriegt er hat es noch
einmal deutlich verschärft was thema
fossile inflation das ist etwas was
ohnehin schon anstand und mit dieser
beschleunigung schaffen wir es auch das
große problem der inflation wieder in
den griff zu bekommen meine damen und
herren
trotzdem wir sind hier in richtig
schweren zeiten so eine inflationsrate
die hat deutschland praktisch seit den
70er jahren nicht gesehen die drohen
tatsächlich eine stagnation zu rutschen
es gibt furchtbare zahlen
unterschiedliche szenarien jetzt schon
freuen entsprechenden ökonomen ökonomen
und umso drastischer und furchtbarer
finde ich ehrlich gesagt den umgang der
cdu mit dieser situation der antrag der
heute vorliegt in der tat ich kennen
ganz viele von den forderungen da
drinstehen weil das evergreens sind aus
der letzten legislaturperiode
die cdu damals mit der spd verhandelt
hat mit der spd nicht hinbekommen hat so
weit so ok aber dieser anschlag hat
nichts mit der aktuellen situation zu
tun ist überhaupt nicht angemessen
überhaupt nicht angemessen und deswegen
könnte ich mir einen schlanken fuß mal
und sagen super habe halt eine schwache
opposition wie gut für die regierung
aber in diesen zeiten in diesen zeiten
brauchen wir eine starke demokratie und
parlamentarismus funktioniert über eine
gute regierung und eine gute opposition
und in diesem sinne in diesem sinne
bitte ich sie insbesondere von der union
ich freue mich schon auf entsprechende
änderungsanträge gesetzgebungsverfahren
nutzen sie ihre chance hier in diesem
hause
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr michael meister
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich finde es ist ein richtiger gedanke
dass die bundesregierung heute in der
situation in der wir sind einen
vorschlag für ein steuerentlastungs
2022 vorlegt und das begrüßen wir auch
grundsätzlich dass ein solcher vorschlag
kommt
allerdings will ich darauf hinweisen der
bundesfinanzminister hat eingangs von
einer gefühlten inflation gesprochen
lieber herr kollege lindner ich glaube
in der lage in der wir sind haben wir
keine gefühlte inflation
sondern wir haben eine objektive
inflation eine inflation die im märz bei
7,3 prozent lag
und die kommt wirklich bei den menschen
im geldbeutel an
und sie haben hier ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz vorgelegt was
auf eine annahme basiert kollege
künstlers vorhin angesprochen von drei
prozent inflation
das ist die hälfte dessen was wir
tatsächlich haben und deshalb sage ich
ihnen der gedanke ist richtig aber er
greift wesentlich zu kurz hier muss
deutlich wer geschickt
sie schlagen vor beim arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag 200 euro sie schlagen vor
beim grundfreibetrag
263 euro und dann wird so schön
formuliert von den kollegen aus der
koalition
naja der grundfreibetrag der hilft dir
allen steuerzahlern weil jedem komplett
und freibetrag zu gute ich will aber an
der stelle mal darauf hinweisen dass sie
die anderen tarif eckwerte nicht
anfassen und was heißt das denn diana
tarifeckwerte nicht anfassen dh sie
bleiben diese sind und das heißt wenn
sie sich das anschauen sie rücken den
grundfreibetrag nach rechts und der rest
bleibt dadurch wäre der steuertarif
steiler das heißt die grenzbelastung
wächst das was sie hier tun ist
leistungsfeindlich und eigentlich
brauchen der situation anderer als
motivation zur leistung und keine
leistungsfeindliche politik
und ich finds ja net voraus dass sie
eben gesagt haben sie warten auf die
vorschläge der opposition
wir haben an der stelle einen klaren
vorschlag gemacht wir möchten alle
tarifeckwerte verändern und den tarif
insgesamt anpassen damit wird diese
leistungsfeindliche politik so nicht
bekommen und alle steuerzahler wirklich
entlasten liebe kollegin hinterlegt
lieber herr kollege show die ich freue
mich auf die gespräche im
finanzausschuss da brauchen sie jetzt
nicht zu schreiben sondern wir sollten
eine sachliche diskussion führen über
die frage wie bei den gesetzentwurf
gestalten sie haben ja an anderer stelle
und auch das ist angesprochen worden
weitere vorschläge gemacht zur
steuerlichen maßnahmen zu
entlastungsmaßnahmen
das halte ich auch für richtig dass wir
die frage diskutieren und ich bin der
meinung sie würden gut daran tun wenn
sie sich daran erinnern dass wir heute
in der ersten lesung sind und dass sie
jetzt als koalition nicht einfach
hingehen und sagen das hat die regierung
vorgelegten das ziehen wir jetzt 1 1
durch die lage hat sich geändert ich
habe es bei der inflation angesprochen
aber dieser gesetzentwurf ist auch
entstanden bevor der angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine begonnen hat und fahrpause
sie haben ja richtig teil ihrer
einschätzung zur allgemeinen
wirtschaftlichen lage es besteht die
gefahr und herr bundesfinanzminister als
auch entsprochen dass wir jetzt in der
situation in eine stagnation hinein
laufen und wenn wir das gemeinsam so
sehen sie aus der regierung seite und
wir aus der opposition dann dürfen wir
nicht warten bis wir in der stagnation
sind sondern wir müssen jetzt maßnahmen
ergreifen dass wir nicht hineinkommen
und deshalb ist es notwendig bezogen auf
inflation bei den bürgern zu entlasten
es ist aber auch notwendig bezogen auf
die wirtschaft dass wir maßnahmen
ergreifen dass wir zusätzliches
wirtschaftliches wachstum generieren und
dazu haben wir in unserem antrag sehr
wohl vorschläge unterbreitet ich nenne
das thema verlust zurücktrat sowohl die
frage der höhe wie auch die frage wie
lange man zurück tragen kann haben wir
angesprochen das ist eine maßnahme
sie haben selbst im koalitionsvertrag
ihrer tour beschreibung wo bleiben ihre
turbo abschreibungen wir verlangen dass
sie haben sie im koalitionsvertrag
machen wir es doch gemeinsam nichts ist
von ihnen zu hören sie schauen betrug
betreten unter sich jetzt werden die
zeit das anzupacken und der wirtschaft
zwischen signal zu geben liebe
kolleginnen und
und ich will an der stelle noch ein
weiteren hinweis geben wo ich auch
dringend handlungsbedarf sehe der
bundesfinanzminister ist nicht
verantwortlich für die geldpolitik das
thema glaube ich uns alle einig
geldpolitik wird von der notenbank
gemacht aber die bundesregierung hat aus
meiner sicht eine verantwortung in der
finanzpolitik der geldpolitik den
notwendigen spielraum zu schaffen damit
man eine vernünftige geldpolitik machen
dann bisher erfüllt sich doch die
notenbank eingeschränkt durch die hohen
schulden die wir in deutschland mehr
unbedingt und in europa haben und
deshalb glaubt die notenbank sie kann
möglicherweise das gar nicht tun was
notwendig wäre in der jetzigen situation
und deshalb fordere ich sie auf jenseits
der steuerpolitik schaffen sie in der
haushaltspolitik die voraussetzungen
dass die notenbank das tun kann was
notwendiges um inflation in diesem land
zu bekämpfen inflation ist die asoziale
politik die es gibt und die dürfen wir
in deutschland nicht zulassen
und ich will in den letzten über merkel
machen zum thema haut office pauschale
ich finde es gut dass wir die haben die
es entstanden in der pandemie aber ich
glaube wir müssen doch zur kenntnis
nehmen auch wenn jetzt was in der
pandemie entstanden ist ist das thema
home office mobiles arbeiten eine
grundsätzliche veränderung der
arbeitswelt und deshalb rege ich an dass
wir in den beratungen mal darüber
nachdenken ob er das von der pandemie
bekämpfung lösen und nicht als
dauereinrichtung schaffen um uns den
veränderungen der arbeitswelt auch in
der steuerpolitik anzupassen und in dem
sinne lade ich sie zu guten gesprächen
ein ich würd mich freuen wenn das
gelingt bei uns haben sie auch einen
ansprechpartner ob das lieber kollege
müller auch innerhalb der koalition
gelingt bin ich skeptisch den kollegen
kaspar zugehört und eben habe ich größe
oder differenzen raus gehört als zu uns
vielen dank und gute beratung
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
bernhard da druck
[Applaus]
ok
wusste gar nicht dass es war ein weiter
so hoch geht hier also
viele kolleginnen und kollegen frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist jetzt von mehreren
betont worden die aktuelle
krisensituation sie fordert
entschlossenes handeln das ist glaube
ich auch hinreichend dokumentiert bei
den kostensteigerungen für strom
lebensmittel heizung mobilität und bei
der noch einmal verschärft angespannten
lage auf den energiemärkten erst recht
und das durchaus auch bei einer
jedenfalls vermeintlich anhaltenden
inflation ich habe dir dort werde die
darstellung des finanzministers hier
überhaupt nicht zu relativieren und zu
kritisieren die war schon so zu treffen
die kosten sind eben ganz
unterschiedlich spürbar an der zapfsäule
bei der miete bei den unternehmen auch
und darauf müssen wir ganz zielgerichtet
reagieren und das machen wir auch heute
jetzt gerade durch diese
steuerentlastungsgesetz wir reden heute
noch über das vierte corona steuer hilfe
gesetz aber eben auch mit anderen
maßnahmen ich will an dieser stelle mal
sagen die der regierungskoalition hat
relativ schnell gehandelt und die
maßnahmenpakete die zur entlastung
dienen macht ein volumen von deutlich
mehr als 30 milliarden euro aus das muss
man schlicht und ergreifend noch mal
wiederholen und deutlich sagen um den
menschen klarzumachen ja wir helfen
tatsächlich mit den vorliegenden
steuerentlastungsgesetz setzen wir ja
maßnahmen aus dem ersten
entlastungspaket um und da sage ich mal
ist jetzt hier angesprochen wurden
anhebung der arbeitnehmer pauschbetrages
von um 200 euro auf 1200 euro
rückwirkend und dann ist gesagt worden
vom bundesfinanzminister das ist in den
letzten elf jahren nicht passiert und es
gab raunen bei der cdu und ich sage mal
so ich empfinde das überhaupt nicht als
einen vorwurf wenn es jetzt die spd und
die fdp und die grünen gemeinsam machen
wenn ihr das kritisiert müsste
eigentlich sozusagen merken dass die
finger auf mich selber zeigen das finde
ich jedenfalls an dieser stelle
grundfreibetrag ist dieselbe sache fritz
güntzler hat gesagt von neun
1984 auf 10.300 47 kommt überwiegend den
geringeren einkommen zugute ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob er das begrüßt hat oder
nicht ich hab es jedenfalls begrüßt ich
find's ganz in ordnung und der meister
sagt das wäre irgendwie
leistungsfeindlich was man sonst nicht
macht der meister wissen sie was
leistungsfeindlich ist
leistungsfeindlich ist es wenn man
leistungslose vermögen nicht hinreichend
besteuert das ist leistungsfeindlich und
dazu lassen sie uns in eine bredouille
bringen aber dann haben sie sich das mal
selber in eine bredouille bringen
befristete anhebung entfernungspauschale
für fernpendler
da will ich aber sagen kollege gerd muss
man darauf hinweisen dass auch die
mobilitäts bremen hier für
geringverdiener wächst von 20 bis zu 120
euro ist auch ein gesichtspunkt die
maria ist keine zwischenfragen mehr
entschuldigungen auch derzeit bin ja eh
der letzte wir berichten heute auch über
weitere steuerliche erleichterungen
drittes coroner steuer hilfe gesetzt
habe ich eben gesagt die verlängerung
der degressiven abschreibung ist eine
massive entlastung und die ist eine
entlastung an der übrigens länder und
kommunen zu zwei dritteln mit beteiligt
sind und ist ein ganz wichtiger schritt
denn sollten sie begrüßen und die
verlängerung der home office pauschale
sozusagen dauerhaft das hätte die auch
in der regierung niemals gemacht haben
wir auch darüber gesprochen also
insofern sollte erinnert euch erinnert
euch einfach mal ich habe die vorschläge
der union gesehen und weiß sie kennen ja
die akteure und schätze die auch
persönlich sie sind so ein bisschen die
sind immer so ein bisschen im rausch der
steuerberatenden berufe sozusagen und
abgeordneten das verstehe ich schon das
verstehe ich schon durchaus aber ich
sage mal nur entlastung für große
vermögen die jetzt nicht wirklich auf
die aktuelle situation
reagieren sind unzureichend ich sag das
noch mal wenn wir uns wirklich sozusagen
als ampel in eine schwierigkeit bringen
wollte dann würde dir die frage mit
vorschlägen verbinden wie denn sozusagen
die finanzierung all der großen ausgaben
auch durch beteiligung großer und
größter vermögen vielleicht gelingen
könnte aber das machen sie gar nicht
weil sie das ja auch gar nicht wollen
und deswegen sage ich mal an dieser
stelle ist das was wir tun der richtige
der richtige weg die unbefristete
verlängert die habe ich schon
angesprochen unsere steuerlichen
maßnahmen entlasten bürgerinnen und
bürger und unternehmen wird sein und
gezielt aber es sind eben auch noch
andere entlastungsmaßnahmen außerhalb
des steuerrechtes die eeg-umlage
beispielsweise bei einer dreiköpfigen
familie 133 euro der heizkostenzuschuss
für wohngeldempfänger
den führen wir ein es wird über
gutachten festgestellt 133 euro so sein
dann verdoppeln wir dass die linken
sagen freundlicherweise hier macht ja
mehr als wir gefordert haben wir
schließen euch uns an und die union sagt
nicht genug und jetzt bei der
entfernungspauschale sind das hier in
bremen habe ich eben gehört der kollege
der linken sagt jetzt unter überholen
die uns schon wieder links also ich sag
mal leute überlegt euch das mal was
gefordert um das uns mit der
glaubwürdigkeit eigentlich zu tun hat
eure eigene
ich will die anderen sachen zu sozialer
ausgewogenheit kurz mal eben auch sagen
die einmalzahlungen für menschen die
arbeitslosengeld 2 oder grundsicherung
beziehen zweimal die sofort zuschlag für
bedürftige kinder bis wir endlich zur
kindergrundsicherung kommen die wir ja
auch verabredet haben wir werden
voraussichtlich noch ein paar weitere
maßnahmen aufnehmen ich sagte dass ein
dort ausdrücklich auch die die
energiepreis pauschale von 300 euro für
einkommen steuerpflichtige erwerbstätige
um selbstständige die wir besteuert ja
ist so ein höheres einkommen macht hat
weniger entlastungen dadurch ist so das
nennt man soziale gerechtigkeit an einer
solchen kleinen stelle was ist daran
schlecht überhaupt nicht finde ich
jedenfalls und
ich sag mal die absenkung der energie
steuern auf kraftstoffe auf das
europäische mindestmaß drei monate lang
30 cent weniger für benzin 14 cent
weniger für diese auch glaube ich
vernünftig aber wichtig ist auch über
kartell und wettbewerbsrechtliche
maßnahmen sicherzustellen dass die
absenkung der energiesteuern und
sinkende rohstoffe rohstoffpreise auch
tatsächlich bei den verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern ankommen ich sag mal die
rebellen vor pauschale 3 x 3 x 9 euro
ist auch eine entlastung gesagt dass
deshalb auch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen weil es falsch ist wenn wir in
der jetzigen situation darauf achten
welche gruppe ist denn eigentlich am
meisten und am wenigsten betroffen wir
hätten rinnen und rentner haben an
vielen stellen von diesen geschichten
auch etwas der heizkostenzuschuss 48
prozent sind rentnerinnen und rentner
aber viel zu wenig rentnerinnen und
rennen wir beantragen wollen das müssten
sie eigentlich machen das wäre sehr viel
vernünftiger ich weiß nicht komme leider
leider muss ich zum schluss kommen aber
ich will noch mal einen tun und sagen in
anknüpfung an das was wir auch gesagt ja
es geht ja nicht nur um diese einzelnen
schnellen hilfsmaßnahmen hast du sag mal
kurz ab punkt seiner karriere schon fast
am ende es geht auch um strukturelle
maßnahmen zu einer höheren resilienz und
zu einer höheren fähigkeit für die
transformation die jetzt in unser paket
beschlossen werden darüber werden wir
die gelegenheit haben demnächst weiter
zu diskutieren herzlichen dank
sagte peer nadal droht der für die spd
fraktion im finanzausschuss also sitzt
unter der letzte gewesen ist in dieser
debatte in dieser ersten beratung des
steuerentlastungsgesetzes
2022 das wird jetzt weiter beraten im
finanzausschuss genauso wie ein antrag
der unionsfraktion mit dem titel mut zu
wesentlichen steuerlichen hilfsmaßnahmen
auch das wie gesagt erst mal im
finanzausschuss und dann in kürze wieder
in zweiter und dritter beratung hier im
plenum des deutschen bundestags wir
schauen auf den nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt es geht um die
ukraine hilfe es geht um
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit und
dafür liegen zwei anträge vor zum einen
eine aus der unionsfraktion der den
titel trägt der ukraine jetzt und in
zukunft helfen
nahrungsmittelversorgung in der welt
sicherstellen sowie europäische und
deutsche landwirtschaft krisenfest
gestalten und es liegt vor einen antrag
aus der spd-fraktion mit dem titel
welthunger ideologiefrei bekennten
stilllegungsflächen rund ökologische
vorrangflächen für nahrungs- und
futtermittel
futtermittelproduktion freigeben knapp
70 minuten sind angesetzt für die
debatte zu diesem punkt die sich wie
gesagt daneben insgesamt mit der
hungersnot und neben der welt
beschäftigen wie sie bekämpft werden
kann wie man abhilfe schaffen kann und
das ganze natürlich auch mit einem
besonderen blick auf die lage die in der
ukraine nicht nur was die bevölkerung
und die ernährung der menschen in der
ukraine angeht sondern jene gilt ja auch
als eine der kornkammern der welt und
viel getreide von dort wird in die welt
exportiert aus der ukraine heraus der
erste redner ist steffen bilger
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion
der russische angriff auf die ukraine
hat entsetzliche folgen zuallererst für
die menschen in der ukraine und die
jüngsten ereignisse erfüllen uns mit
trauer und entsetzen und auch mit wut
und abscheu gegenüber denjenigen die
hierfür verantwortlich sind
die auswirkungen des kriegs spüren wir
in ganz unterschiedlichen bereichen und
einer ist die nahrungsmittelversorgung
wir sorgen uns akut um die versorgung
der menschen im kriegsgebiet wir sorgen
uns um die diesjährige ernte in der
ukraine
der ukrainische landwirtschaftsminister
geht er davon aus dass bis zur hälfte
der diesjährigen landwirtschaftlichen
produktion durch den krieg verloren geht
und wir sorgen uns auch um die
ernährungslage global das eine sind die
kosten von landwirtschaftlichen gütern
insbesondere getreide auf dem weltmarkt
und das andere ist die frage der
verfügbarkeit
30 millionen tonnen getreide aus der
ukraine können zurzeit nicht geliefert
werden wegen des kriegs sagt david
beasley der chef des un
welternährungsprogramms spricht von
einer krise wie das world food program
sie noch nicht erlebt habe in
deutschland werden wir nicht hungern
müssen wir müssen uns aber einstellen
auf teils leere regale darauf dass
bestimmte produkte oder marken mitunter
nicht in den läden zu finden sein werden
oder rationiert werden so wie wir es
heute ja auch schon beim einkauf erleben
aber hungern das werden wir in
deutschland nicht müssen in anderen
regionen der welt kann es aber ganz
schnell anders aussehen und damit sind
wir direkt bei unserer verantwortung
auch ganz konkret in der
landwirtschaftspolitik im bundestag wie
bundesrat nachher bei der abstimmung
über die frage der nutzung von
brachflächen in der bundesregierung und
auf europäischer ebene
der agrarkommissar wotschikowsky sagt
unsere reaktion sollte sein dass wir in
der eu in diesem jahr mehr lebensmittel
mitte produzieren der kollege bußen von
der fdp hat es in der haushaltsdebatte
vor zwei wochen richtig gesagt der druck
flächen zu bewirtschaften statt sie
stillzulegen wird mit jedem tag des
krieges größer
landwirtschaftsminister backhaus von der
spd aus mecklenburg vorpommern sagt es
sei gut und mit blick auf die zu
erwartende verschärfung der
lebensmittelversorgung richtig
brachflächen zeitweise zur
bewirtschaftung freizugeben und jetzt
noch gestern dem ministerpräsidenten
konferenz die einstimmig beschlossen hat
deutschland trifft auch eine humanitäre
verpflichtung einen beitrag zur
weltweiten versorgungssicherheit mit
nahrungsmitteln zu leisten die
ministerpräsidenten fordern die
bundesregierung daher auf die
möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen um das
vorhandene potenzial der landwirtschaft
konsequent zu nutzen so der beschluss
von gestern abend fazit so ziemlich alle
haben es erkannt in der krise geht ein
augen zu und durch nicht klar geht kein
weiter so als wäre nichts passiert die
jetzige krise situation erfordert eine
reaktion und da sind sie gefordert herr
minister ärzte mir nicht aussitzen
sondern handeln ist jetzt das gebot der
stunde
fragt man nach argumenten für die
position des aussitzens dann hört man
ein gebetsmühlenartige mentor für die
eine krise nicht gegen die andere
ausspielen aber das ist mir meine damen
und herren mit verlaub ein bisschen zu
schlicht um es klar zu sagen wir wollen
keine abkehr von unserer
nachhaltigkeitszielen aber manchmal
verlangt eben die bittere realität
vorübergehend andere prioritäten sie
sagen ja immer man sollte jetzt nicht
die alten sprechzettel hervorholen wird
man sagen meine sprechzettel sind
ziemlich neu aber ihre scheinen den
alten grünen parteiprogramm zu
entstanden und die passen einfach nicht
in diese zeit mein dank an
wenn globale hungersnöte und massive
marktverwerfungen und dann ist in
gunstlagen wie bei uns in mitteleuropa
schlichtweg nicht die zeit für eine
weitere extensivierung das wäre nichts
anderes als zynisch und auch unethisch
meine damen und herren wir nochmal till
backhaus von der spd zitieren bei der
agrarministerkonferenz vergangene woche
hat er mit blick auf die grünen
landwirtschaftsminister im bund und in
den ländern gesagt in meiner wahrnehmung
zitiere wurde beschwichtigt und
beschädigt ohne die realitäten
anzuerkennen und die entsprechenden
schlüsse daraus zu ziehen das spricht
doch wirklich bände was ist jetzt zu tun
konkret in deutschland muss jetzt auf
brachliegenden flächen der anbau von
nahrungsmitteln möglich sein und die
2023 geplante pflicht zur stilllegung
von vier prozent der ackerflächen muss
aufgehoben werden
wir können uns ein weiteres grünes
zaudern und zögern nicht erlauben
umdenken ist jetzt das gebot der stunde
das gilt im übrigen auch für die
deutsche verhandlungsführung in brüssel
beim green deal hier braucht die
bundesregierung dringend ein update und
wir brauchen die verhandelten grünen
minister habe krämpfe und letzte mir
dringend den klaren arbeitsauftrag jetzt
ist nicht die zeit für weitere belastung
weder für die landwirtschaft noch für
die verbraucher jetzt gehört die
ernährungssicherung in den mittelpunkt
steffen bilger war das stellvertretende
vorsitzende der unionsfraktion war der
erste redner in einer debatte in der es
um die nahrungsmittelversorgung in der
welt geht aber speziell auch in der
ukraine beziehungsweise auch darum was
aus der ukraine an nahrungsmittel
insbesondere getreide
exportiert wird nächste rednerin ist
natalie public aus der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen seit
über sechs wochen herrscht krieg in der
ukraine
völkerrecht kriegsrecht und
menschlichkeit werden gebrochen die
menschen erleben unbeschreibliches leid
die schrecklichen bilder aus botschaft
lassen das ausmaß der grausamkeiten
dieses krieges nur an
doch der krieg hat nicht nur dramatische
folgen für die ukraine russland oder
europa sondern für die ganze
weltgemeinschaft den putin schafft nicht
nur unendliches leid in der ukraine
sondern nach hunger in der welt
die ukraine und aus russland sind
wichtige produzenten und exporteure für
lebensmittel allein im letzten jahr
wurden knapp
70 millionen tonnen an getreide aus der
ukraine exportiert das
welternährungsprogramm bezieht etwa 30
prozent des getreides aus der ukraine
der wegfall der ukraine als
nahrungsmittelproduzenten bedeutet dass
viele länder ihren bedarf an getreide
nicht mehr decken können und millionen
menschen die hungersnot droht
betroffen sind vor allem länder des
globalen südens die auf das
welternährungsprogramm und auf getreide
importe angewiesen sind es sind länder
wieder jemand nigeria und bangladesch
die sowieso schon zu den ärmsten der
armen gehören
es ist unsere humanitäre verpflichtung
einen beitrag zu leisten und für die
nahrungsmittelsicherheit in der welt zu
sorgen
wir benötigen schnelle internationale
lösungen um eine weltweite hungerkrise
zu verhindern dazu gehört es natürlich
auch dass wir die lebensmittelproduktion
in europa steigern und alles dafür tun
um die märkte offen zu halten
als konsequenz hat die cdu csu fraktion
aber auch gefördert den zwölf euro
mindestlohn in für die landwirtschaft
auszusetzen genauso wie die 70 tage
regelung für die saison beschäftigten
auszuweiten wenn ihnen nichts mehr
einfällt dann kommen sie mit lohndumping
ich weiß dass einige von ihnen sich
nicht einfügen können dass es menschen
gibt die gerade am ende des monats sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie ihr auto
volltanken oder ob sie lebensmittel
einkaufen gehen nicht wenige davon
arbeiten in der landwirtschaft diese
menschen brauchen gerade jetzt eine
solidargemeinschaft die ihnen zur seite
steht die erhöhung des mindestlohns eine
frage von respekt und
auch wenn sie selbst in ihrer letzten
antrags fassung die forderung nach der
verschiebung der erhöhung des
mindestlohns wieder rausgenommen haben
bleibt es dabei dass sie diese krise
dafür nutzen wollen um sozialpolitische
und ökologische rückschritte zu
erreichen oder sonst werden wir mit der
sozialdemokratie so nicht mittragen
die krise darf nicht auf dem rücken
derer ausgetragen werden die hart
arbeiten aber wenig haben vor allem ist
der vorschlag aber auch realitätsfern
denn wenn die arbeit wenn wir die
arbeits und lohnbedingungen in der
landwirtschaft nicht verbessern wird es
am ende keine arbeitskräfte mehr geben
die diese arbeit verrichten in zeiten
des fachkräftemangels werden andere
sektoren die fachkräfte abwerben
lohndumpings vertreibt arbeitskräfte
der krieg in der ukraine die steigenden
preise für energie und dünger aber auch
benzin belasten die landwirtschaft enorm
natürlich wird sich der mindestlohn auch
für die landwirtinnen und landwirte
finanziell bemerkbar machen für die
unterstützung landwirtschaftlicher
betriebe
haben wir aber auch einige instrumente
in unserem koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten die wichtig sind so wollen
wir zum beispiel die und untergrenzen
einführen dass der verkaufspreis eben
nicht unter die kosten der produktion
und der arbeitskraft fällt auch wollen
wir eine herkunftskennzeichnung um die
regionale landwirtschaft zu stärken
knochenjobs auf dem acker für löhne von
denen man nicht leben kann hingegen sind
keine antwort auf die krise das es
ausbeutung meine damen und herren wir
wollen faire preise für hochwertige
produkte aber auch diejenigen die diese
produkte produkte produzieren müssen
sich diese leisten können das gehört zum
anstand dazu ihre antrag ist nicht
weitgehend genug sie spalten unsere
gesellschaften deswegen wir werden wir
diesen ablehnen
natalie patrick war das aus der
spd-fraktion sie ist mitglied im
ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft und überhaupt nicht
einverstanden mit den hier vorliegenden
anträgen was nicht weiter überraschend
ist weil sie ja aus der unionsfraktion
und der
die kommen und insofern aus der
opposition in diesem fall wird der
fehler ist er rät nächster redner auf
die fraktion mitglied im ausschuss für
ernährung und landwirtschaft und wie
gesagt die hälfte hat auch einen eigenen
antrag in dieser debatte ich bin diese
debatte eingebracht wir begrüßen es dass
wir heute wieder über diese wichtigen
themen sprechen können hilfe für die
ukraine hilfe für die dortigen landwirte
aber auch natürlich über
lebensmittelsicherheit
selbstversorgungsgrad hier in
deutschland
ich frage mich nur wer die kollegen von
der cdu csu ich frage mich nur warum
verweigert sie sich eigentlich im
ausschuss immer dieser themen genau das
was sie heute fordern haben wir in
teilen auch in anträgen vorgelegt bitte
finden sie sich noch einmal ein in die
oppositionsrolle und stärken sie die
opposition in diesem hause
ja sie haben es doch vorgestern im
ausschuss oder mittwoch mitbekommen
daten wir gefragt die staatssekretärin
wo wir in dieser schweren zeit in
kriegszeiten ob wir da die
priorisierungen etwas ändern können
klimaziele 23 jahre nach hinten schieben
und endlich den hunger zu bekämpfen und
sie wissen sie wissen wird brutal wie
eiskalt die antwort war ideologie vor
hungersnot ideologie vor dem schutz
unserer landwirte und da hätten wir sie
gebrauchte hätten sie opposition sein
müssen die wir kollegen
sie haben viele punkte richtig heute in
ihrem antrag drin das unterstützen wir
auch und wir haben ist ja ähnlich
beantragt aber bitte bleiben sie bei der
lagebeurteilung um bei der
ursachenanalyse
fair und bleiben sie der bitte korrekt
warum haben denn unsere landwirte diese
herausforderungen sie waren es doch die
die immensen preissteigerungen bei den
rohstoffen und düngemitteln mit zu
verantworten haben die inflation ist auf
einem rekordhoch seit 40 jahren hoch war
sie aber schon vor dem ukraine klinik
sie waren es doch die den euro durch die
eu rettungspolitik verbessert haben die
energiepreise schnell in die höhe sie
haben doch die verkorkste energiewende
mit zu verantworten und das lassen wir
ihnen nicht durchgehen liebe kollegen
muss ich ihnen jetzt wirklich vorrechnen
was 16 jahre merkel-regierung für die
deutschen landwirtschaft gebracht hat
es waren 18.000 es waren nicht wird
50.000 es sind
140000 bäuerliche betriebe die
aufgegeben haben die aufgeben mussten
weil sie nicht weiter arbeiten konnten
und das lassen wir nicht durchgehen
diese agrarpolitik haben sie zu
verantworten
[Applaus]
schauen wir mal konkret in den antrag
rein was bitteschön wollen sie denn mit
inflations beratungsstellen das ist doch
absurd wollen sie den landwirten
erklären was sie bei 7 prozent inflation
bei zwölf prozent inflation oder bei 15
prozent inflation machen sollen eine
spürbare entlastung unserer landwirte
das ist jetzt das gebot der stunde liebe
kollegen
es geht jetzt darum die
lebensmittelpreise für unsere
bevölkerung stabil zu halten
seit montag spüren wir in den
supermärkten in den discountern die
angezogenen preise und das sind die
erzeugerpreise noch gar nicht abgebildet
das ist noch gar nicht berücksichtigt
das ist erst der anfang der
preissteigerung täter auf noch auf uns
zukommen wird die lebensmittel müssen
doch für unsere bürger bezahlbar bleiben
liebe kollegen von der cdu csu kommen
sie erst einmal an in der opposition
dann werden sie ihren anträge vielleicht
in zukunft zustimmen ich danke ihnen
bitterfelder aus der fdp fraktion in
einer debatte des bundestages über die
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit aber
auch und besonders in der ukraine und in
dieser debatte redet jetzt renate künast
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
sprecherin genau für diesen
themenbereich nämlich ernährung und
landwirtschaft
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin ich krieg
mich runter
also danke sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
lilo kolleginnen und kollegen
der chef des world food programms david
base lee hat gesagt der krieg der
ukraine führt zu einer katastrophe und
top zu einer bestehenden katastrophe
warum weil das wort food programm schon
vor dem krieg 125 millionen menschen
ernähren musste 125 millionen menschen
durch die verteuerung von lebensmitteln
war es da schon klar dass sie monatlich
71 millionen dollar mehr an ausgaben
schultern mussten deshalb hatten wir ja
die hinweise zum beispiel im jemen auf
gekürzte
lebensmittelrationen und ich finde es
wirklich mag aber dass sie ja zu tun als
würden die probleme des welthungers
gerade mit dem krieg auf die ukraine
erst entstehen nein sie haben sie vorher
wirklich sehen wollen meine damen und
herren
sie beziehen sich auf die ukraine
die exportiert etwa 70 millionen tonnen
getreide jedes jahr weizen mais andere
sorten fast ein drittel der globalen
weizenexporte stammte schon vor dem
krieg aus russland und der ukraine viele
länder der nahe osten afrika waren
angewiesen und gleichzeitig immer das
makabre zu sagen hat kenia jetzt glaube
dritte jahr der auch gleichzeitig hat
kenia tausende tonnen blumen nach europa
exportiert darin sehen sie das in
unserer ernährungslage etwas schief
liegt damit müssen wir uns beschäftigen
jetzt kommen sie mit einem antrag
der sagt zum beispiel international
organisation stärken so weit so gut dann
sagen sie den griedel war hier beim
redner aus hof und die gab also wie
gemeinsamen agrarpolitik der eu
vorurteilsfrei bewerten und schon ich
habe jetzt gedacht will kommt die
vorurteilsfreie bewertung aber schon
kommt übliche ideologische bewertungen
brachflächen aussetzen pestizideinsatz
ausweiten die die agrarpolitik reform um
ein jahr verschieben meine damen und
herren das kenne ich seit mindestens 20
jahren daran ist nichts neues geld über
also mindestens 20 jahre alte baby gehe
ich mal auf die beratung 1 4 prozent der
agrarflächen sind brachen
stillgelegte flächen die die erträge am
ende aber kaum geschmälert haben warum
weil das grants ertrag standorte sind im
wesentlichen so sagt man das in der
fachsprache da sind gewässerrandstreifen
andere landschaftselemente wo ich sage
danke an cem özdemir und das ministerium
dass sie an dieser stelle stand halten
und dazu eines machen dass man den
aufwuchs nutzen kann als futtermittel
das ist die effektivste art etwas zu
nutzen weil wenn sie umgekehrt was
machen was die cdu will diese dinge die
schwer zu bearbeiten sind dann auch noch
mit pestiziden versehen meine damen und
herren dann ist der ertrag geringer als
die ökologische belastung das können sie
nicht ernsthaft wollen
ja geringe erträge schwer zu
bewirtschaften das gilt für diese fläche
und selbst wenn wir die stilllegung
aufheben würden meine damen und herren
wäre das eine erhöhung der eu
getreidemenge um 4,4 prozent auf die
weltweite produktion weil sie wollen ja
mit dieser geschichte die welt ernähren
auf die weltweite produktion werden dass
0,4 prozent mit 0,4 prozent wollen sie
die welt retten nehmen meine damen und
herren das beleidigt unseren internet
und sie wollen mit den schlechtesten ab
standorten und den geringsten erträgen
bei uns die die bauern gerne
stilllegen und dafür noch geld kriegt
meine damen und herren mit diesen 0,4
prozent wollen sie nicht nur die welt
retten sondern die wunderbaren böden der
ukraine ersetzen das glaubt kein mensch
und dann kommen sie noch pestizide auf
diesen fast ertraglosen standorten
einsetzen sie haben aber doch zeitgleich
gesagt dass die bauern belastet sind
weil die pestiziden preise steigen wenn
sie dass da auch noch einsätzen auf 4
prozent der flächen steigen die pestizid
preise noch weiter was wollen sie
eigentlich
in deutschland werden die
stilllegungsflächen zurzeit 350.000
hektar
350.000 hektar allein die anbaufläche
für winterweizen in der ukraine waren
6,4 millionen 6,45 millionen hektar sie
wollen also mit 350.000 6 und 6 4 5
millionen hektar ersetzen und dann noch
die welt ernähren meine damen und herren
wenn sie wirklich ernsthaft fast wollen
dann reden sie mit über die hard facts
wenn wir zum beispiel 30 prozent der
schweinehaltung reduzieren dann würden
würden wir eine million hektar fläche
einsparen meine damen und herren das
wären beitrag zur welternährung und zwar
egal ob die fläche bei unserer woanders
anfällt dann könnte man damit menschen
ernähren folgen sie doch bitte und
besser 600 wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die drei hebel
vorschlagen nämlich dass wir die
kurzfristigen shops bewältigen dass wir
uns konzentrieren auf die menschliche
gesundheit und langfristig nachhaltige
entwicklung gewährleisten sehen sie
der hebel 1 ist
zwei punkten zwei drittel der
ackerfläche in deutschland nutzen wir
für futtermittel wenn wir das reduzieren
haben wir eben fünf millionen tonnen
getreide dazu sagen sie kein wort meine
damen und herren gebe zwei mehr
hülsenfrüchte weitere ökologisierung das
würde heißen die fahrt fort strategie
der eu die ja den stickstoff überschuss
halbieren den ökolandbau ausweiten will
unterstützen wie cem özdemir ist tut
kein wort von ihm dazu das wollen sie
lieber nach hinten schieben und ehrlich
gesagt glaubt kein mensch das ist nur
ein jahr nach hinten schieben wollen
und dann der hebel 3
lebensmittelverschwendung auch kein wort
von ihnen dazu meine damen und herren
ich sage ihnen eins die grundlage der
landwirtschaft unserer ernährung sind
gesunde würden ausreichend wasser
stabiles klima eine reichhaltige
artenvielfalt um deutschland hat allein
in den letzten 20 jahren so viel wasser
verloren wie der bodensee wasser hat
dazu sagen sie auch nicht sie wollen nur
reformen die die landwirtschaft
unterstützen nach hinten schieben sie
wollen allenfalls kleine und kosmetische
wirklich kleine kosmetische
operationen die am ende aber nicht
helfen um ein letzter satz meine damen
und herren es gibt auf dieser welt genug
nahrungsmittel potenziell sie sind aber
falsch verteilt sie warten falsch
genutzt meine damen und herren wir
wollen die reform weitermachen um
wirklich dieses jahr und in zukunft
menschen zu ernähren und deshalb bin ich
froh dass die erhaltungs und an der
stelle zwar bei der fütterung hilft aber
nicht kaputt macht was uns erhält danke
renate künast sprecherin für ernährung
und landwirtschaft der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen hält den antrag der
unionsfraktion zur
nahrungsmittelversorgung für nicht
effizient bzw gewinnbringend die
maßnahmen gegen vorgeschlagen sind hören
wir was ihn altendorf dazu sagt sie ist
in der linksfraktion sprecherin für
landwirtschaft ländliche räume und
tierschutz präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte kollegen von der
fraktion von der unionsfraktion wenn sie
erfordern nahrungsmittelversorgung
sicherstellen landwirtschaft krisenfest
gestalten wissen sie auch dass es die
probleme schon viel länger gibt und die
ursachen tiefer liegen die defizite sind
durch den krieg in der ukraine
wie durch ein brennglas sichtbar
geworden und ja sie wurden auch für heft
aber
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wir haben es eben gerade aufgehört haben
vor wenigen tagen fachübergreifend in
einem offenen brief festgestellt die
weltweite nahrungssicherheit wird nicht
durch die einschränkung des
nahrungsmittels angebotes verursacht
sondern durch eine ungleiche verteilung
dass es fakt und das wissen sie
jahrzehnte lang haben sie die
möglichkeit zur veränderung verschlafen
davon wollen sie jetzt nichts wissen
unsere forderung nach einer sozial
gerechten und ökologischen
landwirtschaft national und
international haben sie immer abgelehnt
dieser antrag der union ist ein
rundumschlag mit dem ganz viel auf
einmal angepackt werden soll ja und es
gibt auch gute ansätze bei der forderung
zum beispiel nach einem sonderprogramm
zur abfederung der gravierendsten folgen
steigender nahrungsmittelpreise oder ihr
ruf nach einer internationalen
preiskontrolle aber ich bezweifle ob sie
das auch wirklich wollen vor allem wenn
man bedenkt dass auch mit ihnen quasi in
einer ganz großen koalition
das 100 milliarden rüstungsprojekte im
raum steht dadurch werden mittel für den
sozial ökologischen umbau der
gesellschaft und auch der agrarpolitik
auf jahre
ja auch wir wollen die entwicklungshilfe
aufstocken
ich habe es gerade in der letzten
sitzungswoche an dieser stelle massiv
kritisiert dass die
entwicklungshilfegelder im haushalt
gekürzt wurden es muss mehr und nicht
weniger geld für eine echte
entwicklungsarbeit in den ländern
eingesetzt werden aber solange wir durch
dumpingpreise und exportgüter den
heimischen bauern die erwerbs- und
lebensgrundlage zerstören haben wir
nichts gelernt
entwicklungshilfe muss dazu beitragen
den winden hat wieder aufzubauen für
dinge die in den ländern auch selbst
produziert werden können und auch hier
gilt regionale wirtschaftskreisläufe
sind zu stärken anstatt die profitgier
von konzernen zu bedienen national und
international
wir brauchen in den entwicklungsländern
und auch hierzulande endlich eine
rückbesinnung auf die eigene
ernährungssouveränität zum beispiel
durch den aufbau von regionalen
wirtschaftskreisläufen die verhandlungen
auf augenhöhe zwischen produzenten und
abnehmer die kostendeckende produktion
bezahlbaren bogen und die ausreichende
honorierung von agrarumweltmaßnahmen
hierdurch würden die kleineren und
mittleren unternehmen gestärkt
heute der größte teil des gewinns bei
der vermarktung das wissen wir der
reibach wird in der mittelmeer gemacht
bei handelsketten und konzern auf der
strecke bleiben am einen ende die
produzenten und am anderen ende die
konsumenten ändern sie das mit uns
und die beamten fraktion von einer
begrenzung der marktmacht im handel ist
bei ihnen nicht die rede sie setzten
sogar noch einen drauf die ohnehin zu
kritisierende 70 tage regelung für
saison arbeiter- und saison arbeiterin
als kurzfristige beschäftigte ohne
soziale absicherung wollen sie auf 115
tage ausweiten das ist der falsche
reflex wir sehen den schraubstock in dem
sich die landwirte befinden als erzeuger
aber der druck darf nicht nach unten
weitergegeben werden da an die
beschäftigten das ist der falsche weg
wir fordern eine faire bezahlung und vor
allem vollen sozialen schutz
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren um
die nationalen europäische
landwirtschaft krisenfest zu machen
bedeutet dass es wesentlich mehr als das
herumdoktern an symptomen
und das blinde vertrauen in die nicht
vorhandenen sogenannten
selbstheilungskräfte des marktes das
system gehört vom kopf auf die füße
gestellt vielen dank
in ladendorf aus der fraktion die linke
sprecherin für landwirtschaft ländliche
räume und tierschutz und umwelt einen
ganz bestimmten aspekt heraus zugreifen
der hier durchaus seine rolle spielt
nämlich exporte aus der ukraine eben
beispielsweise
pflanzenöl oder weizen aber auch metalle
da stehen in der ukraine im moment fast
24.000 waggons mit exportgütern und
warten darauf die ukrainische west
grenze zu überqueren also auch
waren die hier im westen erwartet werden
und gleichzeitig kommt die meldung der
deutschen presseagentur von vor wenigen
minuten dass bei einem raketenangriff
auf den bahnhof der ostukrainischen
stadt krems nach offiziellen angaben
dutzende menschen getötet und verletzt
worden sind also auf der einen seite das
drama um tote und verletzte auf der
anderen seite aber auch weitere
schwierigkeiten was den transport von
gütern angeht in der ukraine
das ist glaube ich auch oder sind auch
ein zwei punkte die man im zusammenhang
mit lisa debatte nicht aus den augen
verlieren sollte wir schauen auf den
nächsten redner gero clemens hocker ist
das aus der fdp-fraktion und dort
landwirtschaftspolitische sprecher
mit jedem tag den der krieg in der
ukraine andauert steigt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass menschen in
anderen ländern in den anderen regionen
dieser welt tatsächlich hunger werden
leiden müssen und natürlich haben sie
liebe frau kollegin künast recht dass
wir das alleine nicht verhindern werden
können aber wir können einen beitrag
leisten dafür ich glaube sogar dass wir
die moralische verpflichtungen haben
einen beitrag zu leisten dafür dass die
preissteigerung in deutschland auch dass
die nöte in ärmeren regionen dieser welt
moderater ausfallen und ich glaube dass
wir wenn wir das nicht tun und eine eine
moralische sackgasse hinein begeben aus
der wir nur ganz schwer wieder
herauskommt wurden
ich weiß übrigens wie schwierig das ist
wenn man
kurzfristige externe ereignisse
sozusagen die eigene meinungsbildung mit
integrieren muss ich sags ganz
unumwunden ich habe als abgeordneter
sächsischen landtages gestritten für die
kernenergie als brückentechnologie als
co2 neutrale technologie hin zu
erneuerbaren energien und dann passierte
fukushima und quasi über nacht wurden
dann an anderer stelle entscheidung
getroffen und dann musste auch seine
eigenen positionen überdenken und am
ende auch revidieren und ich habe das
gemacht um eine partei das gemacht und
ich glaube dass es situationen gibt
meine damen und herren die so mächtig
sind dass man quasi als ewiggestriger
dastehen würde wenn man eben nicht
einlenkt und wenn man nicht seine eigene
haltung seiner eigenen forderungen im
lichte der aktuellen entwicklungen noch
mal auf den prüfstand stellt das war für
mich fukushima und die energiewende
seiner zeit und ich hoffe dass der ein
oder andere hier in diesem haus seiner
haltung aufgrund der jüngsten
entwicklungen des krieges in der ukraine
noch einmal überdenkt gelegen
und an die union gewandt auch wenn der
vorliegende antrag einige punkte richtig
benannt werden wir ihm aus folgenden
gründen ich zustimmen können es
suggeriert nämlich dass die menschen in
diesem land und auch diese
bundesregierung in den vergangenen
wochen und monaten quasi tatenlos
gewesen während bei der bewältigung der
flüchtlingskrise und da will ich ihnen
ganz ausdrücklich sagen herr kollege
thies das ist ein schlag ins gesicht all
derjenigen menschen in diesem lande die
gegenwärtig zusammenrücken um platz zu
machen für flüchtlinge die nach
deutschland kommen die auch keine angst
haben verstanden nebenkosten das ist ein
schlag ins gesicht all der unternehmen
die spenden und auch hier viele
kolleginnen und kollegen ansprechen und
sich erkundigen wie kann die logistik
bewältigt werden das ist ein schlag ins
gesicht all der männer und frauen die in
den ausnahmen gehören arbeiten und tag
und nacht dafür streiten und arbeiten
dass die menschen aus der ukraine hier
eine menschenwürdige unterbringung
bekommen und das ist auch ein schlag ins
gesicht des krisenstabs der
bundesregierung die einen hervorragenden
job macht bei der bewältigung der luft
die herausforderung bei der bewältigung
der flüchtlingssituation fertig
kolleginnen kollegen dialoge
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
bundesregierung hat den anspruch nach
jahrzehnten ökonomie und ökologie
miteinander zu vereinen und ich sage
ihnen mir fällt kein wirtschaftsbereich
ein wo das schon jetzt im jahre 2022
besser gelungen wären und es ist richtig
diesen weg fortzuschreiten aber dieser
ich sage mal konstruierte konflikt den
sie mit ihrem antrag auf machen dass
sozusagen bewirtschaftung von flächen im
gegensatz zur ökologie stünde das ist
eine auffassung aus den 1970 er jahren
wir haben die technologie beides
miteinander zu vereinen gerade bei
unseren landwirten ist es doch
tatsächlich so dass wir das know how
haben dass diejenigen flächen die gerade
landwirtschaftlich genutzt wird häufig
noch eine höhere ökologische bedeutung
haben als diejenigen flächen die einfach
brachliegen und deswegen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen ist ihr antrag
komplett aus der zeit gefallen und wird
nicht unsere zustimmung für den vielen
dank und die sagt gero clemens hocker
aus der fdp-fraktion wo er
landwirtschaftspolitische sprecher ist
an die adresse der unions fraktion die
einen der beiden anträge die hier gerade
diskutiert werden vorgelegt hat der der
ukraine jetzt und in zukunft helfen will
aber auch die nahrungsmittelversorgung
in der welt sicherstellen sowie
europäische und deutsche landwirtschaft
krisenfest gestalten und dazu jetzt aus
der unions fraktion hans jürgen thies
ich glaube sie haben in ihrer rede schon
selbst die antwort darauf gegeben
weshalb wir als union auch in sachfragen
mit ihnen von der afg nicht
zusammenarbeiten können und werden das
nur in replik zu ihnen und frau kollegin
künast ich muss sagen ich bin nicht nur
irritiert ich bin ein stück weit auch
betroffen von ihren ausführungen
ja das muss ich ganz deutlich sagen wenn
sie auf der einen seite sagen ja das
hungerproblem ist nicht neu auf dieser
welt da haben sie völlig recht aber es
ist hungerproblem wird doch massiv
verstärkt durch die jetzige o2 der krise
und wenn sie dann sagen die freigabe von
ökologischen vorrangflächen würde doch
nur im einstelligen prozentbereich oder
sogar 0,9 prozent bereich nur die
produktion erhöhen und steigern aber
wenn es uns auf diese art und weise
gelingt auch nur eine million menschen
weltweit
fortunas nur zusätzlich zu bewahren dann
ist das ein wert an sich und eine
erfolgt und es ist zynisch wenn die das
so lapidar in frage stellen was du dich
nur bei landsleuten schlag ja
kommen sie wieder etwas butter neuer
zeiten erfordern neue entscheidungen und
bitte verstehen sie mich nicht falsch
wir haben im letzten jahr die gap aus
voller überzeugung
mit geschlossen und wir wollen an den
ökologischen umbau wir wollen an den
agrar und klimapolitischen zielen auch
grundsätzlich festhalten das will ich
hier an dieser stelle deutlich sagen um
dieses in frage stellen die union war
verhaftet in den in den entscheidungen
der siebzigerjahre mal klarzustellen
gesteht zu diesem ziel nur wir müssen
doch in der gegenwärtigen
krisensituation die prioritäten anders
setzen das schreibt ihr das
entscheidende zu sein und deswegen geht
es jetzt jetzt geht es darum uhr zu
stellen mehr produktion mehr getreide zu
produzieren um auch ausgleichend auf
dieser rasant steigenden
und getreidepreise zu reagieren durch
den krieg in der ukraine
ist auch für die heimische
landwirtschaft eine völlig neue
gefechtslage entstanden wir brauchen
jetzt kurzfristige lösungen die
eu-kommission hat dazu auch uns
vorgemacht wie die gap richtlinien
gelockert werden können aber herr
bundesminister zu mir gefällt nicht viel
mehr ein als die zusätzliche beweidung
von vorrangflächen das halten wir
deutlich viel zu wenig hatten auch
gehofft als union sie würden maßnahmen
die schon angeschoben worden sind aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ihre doch
sehr seichten ausführungen in der
letzten haushaltsdebatte vor 14 tagen
die haben uns sehr enttäuscht das waren
kurzfristige ankündigung und notwendige
hilfen sorgt auch ein weg gebracht
werden bisher haben wir davon noch
nichts gesehen die haben also programm
mehr erwähnt aber wo sind diese
programme werden sie umgesetzt also es
geht darum jetzt wirklich die
ernährungssicherheit in unserem lande
aber auch weltweit zu sichern eile ist
geboten ua bekämpfung wo es aktuell
vorrang haben vor klimaschutz ich jahre
aktuell und tempo wer so etwas können
wir kurzfristig tun wir brauchen einen
ernährungs gipfel mit allen denkbaren
akteuren angesiedelt im
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium als
zuständigem fach das so und da darf
nicht nur schöngeredet werden da muss
auch gehandelt werden und zunächst
brauchen wir eine bestandsaufnahme
wir brauchen eine bestandsaufnahme
bei welchen nahrungsmitteln gibt es
versorgungsengpässe
wie sieht es um die lieferketten aus was
es mit preis steigen und zwar nicht nur
bei getreide bei lebensmittel sondern
auch zb war den energiekosten und das
ganze muss dann auch noch unter dem
sozial ökonomischen aspekt betrachtet
werden denn das kommt mir in der
diskussion bisweilen etwas zu kurz wir
müssen auch schauen ob er dich die
agrarreform
mindestens um ein jahr verschieben wir
können nicht jetzt an flächen und
stilllegungs programm wie zu
friedenszeiten festhalten wir brauchen
jetzt nicht weniger wir brauchen jetzt
mehr an produktionen das gilt sowohl für
futtermittel als auch für
lebensmittelproduktion unser antrag
enthält dringlicher agrarpolitische
handelspolitische und auch
entwicklungspolitische forderungen an
die bundesregierung um die
ernährungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
herr bundesminister ad sie mir bitte
heben sie sich positiv von dem handlungs
schwachen kabinetts kolleginnen feser
und lambrecht ab werden sie jetzt aktiv
zügig und ergebnisorientiert vielen
herzlichen dank
hans jürgen thies aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion der bundestag
diskutiert über zwei anträge zum thema
welternährung
nahrungsmittelversorgung in der welt
aber auch um den umgang mit stilllegungs
und ökologischen vorrangflächen einem
antrag aus der fdp-fraktion der nächste
redner aus der spd-fraktion manuell gaza
kollege vor mir war etwas größer sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen acht jahre
bleiben uns noch bis 2030 soll es auf
der welt keinen hunger mehr geben das
ist das zweite der 17 weltweit
nachhaltigkeitsziele auf die sich fast
alle staaten der welt verständigt haben
selbst vor dem einsetzen der weltweiten
corona pandemie überliefern überaus
ambitioniertes ziel der brutale
angriffskrieg von putin auch die ukraine
rückt dieses ziel nicht nur in weite
ferne das riskiert auch alles was wir
bislang erreicht haben die ukraine und
russland sind die kornkammern für einen
großteil der welt und das gilt
insbesondere für den globalen 7 auf
russland und die ukraine entfallen etwa
zwölf prozent aller weltweit gehandelten
kilokalorien pro panzer rollen können
keine traktoren fahren wo gekämpft wird
kann nicht gesät und geerntet werden
diese unterbrechung der globalen
versorgungskette trifft import abhängige
länder des globalen südens wie somalia
den libanon jemen unmittelbar und
besonders hatte die preissteigerung auf
den weltmärkten betonen in erster linie
die ernährungssicherheit der ärmsten der
armen im koalitionsvertrag haben wir uns
das ziel gesetzt hunger zu bekämpfen und
weltweite ernährungssicherheit zu
erreichen auch dieses ziel und vor allem
für seine erreichung notwendigen mittel
müssen im lichte der aktuellen
geschehnisse neu bewertet werden denn
ernährung ist ein existenzielles
menschenrecht das nicht profitinteressen
überlassen werden darf
gerade laufen die haushaltsberatung zur
förderung von ernährungsprogramm im
globalen süden der bundeskanzlerin sowie
ministerin svenja schulze haben bereits
zugesichert dass zusätzliche gelder zur
verfügung gestellt werden und dass es
aufgrund der humanitären notlage auch
genau richtig so die angekündigten 430
millionen sind eine wichtige antwort auf
die akute not mit der wir uns im moment
konfrontiert sind ein entscheidender
faktor für die langfristige weltweite
ernährungssicherheit ist der klimawandel
eben völlig richtig angesprochen wo
klima schocks und extremwetter
ereignisse bieten ist der hunger
inwieweit die produktivität von kleinen
bäuerlichen familienbetrieben die 80
prozent übrigens der globalen produktion
ausmachen hängt direkt von
umweltbedingungen wie dem klima der
wasserverfügbarkeit und der
fruchtbarkeit von würden ab
und mit etwas verwunderung musste ich
feststellen dass sie mit dem
bürokratischen hemmnissen bei der
neuordnung der welt warenströme
eigentlich die einhaltung von
menschenrechts- und umweltstandards
meinen und ich versichere ihnen an
dieser stelle dass die wahrung von
menschenrechten nicht der grund für die
aktuellen herausforderungen entlang der
globalen lieferketten sind stattdessen
werden die den neuen eu
rechtsvorschriften den ökologischen
wandel voran bringen für unternehmen
rechtssicherheit schaffen und für mehr
transparenz bei verbrauchern sorgen und
das ist auch gut so
und neben dem ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit nicht so
genau so wie meine vorrednerin natalie
public auch im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales und auch hier saison
arbeiterinnen und erntehelferin
verrichten harte körperliche arbeit
unter sehr schwierigen bedingungen und
häufig zu niedrigen löhnen dieser
zustand riskiert nicht nur die sicherung
ausreichender arbeitskraft im
landwirtschaftssektor sondern führt alle
argumente zugunsten der weltweiten
ernährungssicherung ad absurdum sozial
sanders senken um den hunger zu
bekämpfen das ist eine mehr als
fragwürdige strategie
das problem der niedrigen erzeugerpreise
für agrar produkte und der mangel an
beschäftigten in der landwirtschaft darf
und kann nicht gelöst werden indem man
sozialstandards sind
anstatt sozial und umweltstandards
preiszugeben brauchen wir jetzt
kraftvolle maßen haben sowie die bereits
inszenierten nothalt nothilfe
finanzierungen und langfristige lösungen
für die strukturellen probleme in der
landwirtschaft und sehr geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen der cdu csu
fraktion in ihrem antrag stehen durchaus
sinnvolle dinge gerade im bereich der
finanzierung da kann man denke ich in
einem bereich mit gehen wovon allerdings
auch die bundesregierung schon einiges
bearbeitete einiges auf den weg gebracht
wurde dass wir uns in dieser schwierigen
situation konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten
auf alle 22 punkte konnte in diesen fünf
minuten jetzt nicht eingehen aber ich
hoffe ich habe einige geschafft und
meinen dank das ist mir an dieser stelle
nochmal besonders wichtig geht an die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer an alle dort
aber in dieser debatte ganz besonders an
die menschen in der landwirtschaft
arbeiten in der logistik die unter
katastrophalen schwierigen umständen
gerade einen wahnsinnigen job machen und
alles rausholen was geht und ich bin
ihnen sehr dankbar und meine fraktion
und die regierungsfraktion ich glaube
das ganze haus sendet ein ganz großes
zeichen der solidarität in der ukraine
mit 100
megawatt noch mal an die menschen
der ukraine und ihre mehr als schwierige
lage in diesen wochen während der
bundestag über ukraine hilfen redet über
nahrungsmittelversorgung eben auch mit
der nahrungsmittel für über die
nahrungsmittelversorgung in der ukraine
es liegen zwei anträge vor unter anderem
einer aus der spd-fraktion und hierzu
jetzt bernd und schattner eben aus der
fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die extensivierung der landwirtschaft in
den vergangenen drei jahrzehnten hat zu
einem dramatischen rückgang der
tierhaltung und der damit verbundenen
eigenversorgung des landes mit
nahrungsmitteln geführt lebensmittel
wurden als ramschware angesehen unsere
heimischen landwirte als angebliche
große co2 verursacher abgestempelt und
damit zum feindbild der gesellschaft in
deutschland deklariert schon vor der
ukraine krise sind enorme anstieg der
erzeugerpreise für milch fleisch und
getreide und zu verzeichnen gewesen
davon profitiert haben aber in keinster
weise unsere landwirte da die
produktionskosten noch deutlich stärker
gewachsen sind aber was sind denn die
gründe für diese preisexplosion bei
nahrungsmitteln kraftstoffen und
mineraldünger es ist genau ihre links
grüne politik die mit sätzen wie weniger
fleisch zu essen wäre ein beitrag gegen
putin oder wir brauchen jetzt ein
temporäres tempolimit auf unseren
autobahnen um so schnell es geht
unabhängig von russischem öl zu werden
die grammatik dieses stammt übrigens von
der bundesvorsitzenden der partei der
grünen frau lang selbst diese beiden
sätze zeigen exemplarisch auf der
bundesregierung fehlt der nötige
sachverstand um die aktuellen probleme
zu meistern
ihre aktuelle politik sorgt lediglich
dafür dass deutsche bürger zunehmend
verarmen und unternehmen ins ausland
abwandern und arbeitsplätze bei uns
vernichtet werden die bundesregierung
mit ihrer glorreichen inflationspolitik
hat es in einem halben jahr im amt
geschafft dass sie bei einer
inflationsrate im märz von mittlerweile
über sieben prozent stehen solche
steigerungsraten bei gleichzeitiger
nullzinspolitik hat keine regierung in
den letzten jahrzehnten zu verantworten
gehabt dadurch sind beispielsweise für
landwirte die mineralien die kosten
allein im letzten halben jahr um 600
prozent gestiegen dies führt zu einer
steigerung des getreidepreises und damit
auch zu preiserhöhungen bei den
lebensmitteln konzern von bis zu 50
prozent die jeder bürger ihrem land
tragen muss und jetzt liebe grüne wollen
sie den bauern noch bis zu sieben
prozent ihrer ackerflächen stilllegen
diese maßnahme mit 1300 euro je hektar
an steuergeldern vergüten
zusammengefasst ist dann dazu zu tragen
dass die bundesregierung den landwirten
ein produktionsverbot erteilt was der
deutsche bürger mit steuern bezahlt und
als belohnung darf er noch erheblich
teurere lebensmittel bezahlen wir
fordern daher diese fachliche unkenntnis
zu beenden und den deutschen landwirten
das freie produzieren von nahrungs und
futtermitteln auf den angedachten
stilllegungs und ökologischen
vorrangflächen zu ermöglichen mit dieser
maßnahme wird nicht nur die
nahrungsmittelpreise in den deutschen
supermärkten wie das hinten sondern wir
könnten allein durch diese intensive
nutzung der angedachten 7%
stilllegungsflächen in europa den
getreide import von fast ganz
nordamerika 100 afrika abdecken die
gegen kommission ist unseren forderungen
bereits gefolgt nun haben auch die die
vernunft herr minister und fördert die
produktion heimischer nahrungs und
futtermitteln und eben nicht den hunger
in der welt stimmen sie unseren bei
gestellten antrag zu vielen dank
während schatten aus und für die fw
fraktion er ist mitglied im ausschuss
für ernährung und landwirtschaft die
nächste rednerin wird den blick
mutmaßlich etwas weiter ziehen über
deutschland hinaus den deborah döring
die jetzt gleich bereiches kommt aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und sie
ist entwicklungspolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion muss also das große ganze
und globale im blick behalten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen weltweit
hungern zurzeit über 800 millionen
menschen das entspricht der bevölkerung
der eu und nordamerika zusammen aber wer
sich jetzt hier hinstellt und einfach
nur mehr weizenproduktion gepaart mit
weniger klimaschutz fordert der hat das
problem in gänze nicht verstanden
44 millionen menschen stehen kurz vor
dem hungertod und die zahl steigt rasant
an deswegen brauchen wir jetzt eine
massive aufstockung des chronisch
unterfinanzierten
welternährungsprogramms wir müssen den
akuten hunger bekämpfen ja aber das
allein reicht nicht aus wir haben
aktuell genug lebensmittel in der welt
sie sind einfach nur ungerecht verteilt
und das ist auch an sich keine neue
erkenntnis aber wenn ich mir die anträge
und die redebeiträge hier so anhöre dann
scheint es wohl noch nicht bei allen
hier im plenum angekommen zu sein
unsere freihandelspolitik hat die
abhängigkeit des globalen südens von
nahrungsmittelimporten geschaffen zu den
aktuellen krisen haben wir in der eu und
mit unserem weltwirtschaftssystem
beigetragen diese politik hat
lokale ernährungssystem systematisch
zerstört kleinbäuerinnen verdrängt und
die übermacht von multinationalen
konzernen begünstigt und liebe union
ihre verweigerungshaltung der letzten 16
jahre die klimakrise konsequent nicht
anzugehen hat auch dazu geführt dass
tausende von menschen auf der suche nach
wasser und weideland jetzt schon
vertrieben werden klima die
krisenbedingte dürfen und heuschrecken
plagen führen zu massiven ernteausfällen
und werden es auch weiter tun deswegen
müssen wir mehr klimaschutz fordern und
nicht weniger
und in zügen hinzu kommt dann gerade
noch die krone pandemie tick zu extrem
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
verwerfungen im globalen süden geführt
hat in den letzten zwei jahren sind die
lebensmittelpreise gerade wegen dieser
polit an die noch weiter rasant in die
höhe gestiegen der krieg gegen die
ukraine hat diese preis problematik noch
einmal verschärft staaten müssen sich
jetzt weiter zu verschulden damit sie
das brot für ihre bevölkerung
subventionieren damit sie das durch
überhaupt noch leisten können in einigen
ländern im globalen süden geben familien
mehr über als 60 prozent ihres gesamten
einkommens für nahrungsmittel aus und
genau das meine ich wenn ich sage diese
krisen hängen zusammen sie verstärken
sich gegenseitig und es gibt keine
eindimensionalen lösungen aller union
für diese mehrdimensionalen probleme
wir müssen aufhören mit kurzfristig
gedachten lösungen diese langfristigen
probleme anzugehen klima und
umweltschutz darf nicht gegen
ernährungssouveränität ausgespielt
werden stattdessen müssen wir an die
strukturen ran ansonsten stehen wir doch
bei den nächsten krisen genauso da wie
wir jetzt dastehen wir brauchen den
biologischen umbau der globalen
landwirtschaft wir müssen
nahrungsmittelspekulationen regulieren
und schulden moratorien ermöglichen wir
müssen die globalen ernährungssystem
endlich resilient machen das gilt es
jetzt anzugeben
dafür müssen wir vor einigen im globalen
süden die lokale produktion und
vermarktung von lebensmitteln wieder in
gang bringen wir müssen klein waren
kleinbauern im globalen süden wir
brauchen agrarökologe ansätze die
ausgebaut werden um die abhängigkeit von
pestiziden und mineraldünger zu
verringern im globalen norden ja auch
hier müssen wir handeln und wir müssen
die nahrungsmittel verschwendung
drastisch reduzieren und auch wenn das
einigen könig passt ja das bedeutet auch
dass wir werden lernen müssen weniger
tierische produkte zu konsumieren
und da der kollege der afg gestern dann
mir wieder anfing die gleichberechtigung
in frage zu stellen auch hier nochmal
ganz klar und deutlich wir müssen die
gleichberechtigung der geschlechter
voranbringen denn der hunger auf der
welt kann nur besiegt werden wenn
weiblich gelesene menschen endlich
gleichberechtigt sind weltweit sichern
vor einigen frauen die ernährung ihrer
familie aber sie werden nicht gehört sie
werden unsichtbar gemacht bäuerinnen
sind der motor für
ernährungssouveränität und ihre
potenziale und fähigkeiten brauchen wir
um den hunger der welt zu überwinden und
das werden wir angehen
hat ihr hd strukturen zu stürzen müssen
wir die rechten von frauen stärken ich
komme gar nicht unter die haben mir
jetzt zu
stadtzentrum müssen wir länder endlich
ermöglichen soziale sicherung systeme
aufzubauen wir müssen menschenrechte vor
profit stellen wir müssen
menschenwürdige arbeitsbedingungen
schaffen wir brauchen eine agrar
ökologische transformation mit fairen
und gerechten handel
ernährungssouveränität und
verteilungsgerechtigkeit werden wir
angehen das sind langfristige lösungen
liebe union
die bohrung für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen und sie haben gesehen es
gibt unterschiedliche arten und weisen
auf beiträge zu reagieren hier haben sie
eine ganz spezielle zum schluss noch
einmal gehabt christoph hoffmann ist der
nächste redner stellvertretender
vorsitzender eben ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung und er ist mitglied der
fdp-fraktion im bundestag
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
guten tötet
putin tötet und zerstört
putin tötet in der ukraine aber auch in
den entwicklungs und schwellenländern
der un-generalsekretär antonio guterres
sieht ein wirbelsturm des hungers kommen
in kenia uganda somalia überall
explodieren die lebensmittelpreise und
im südlichen afrika beispielsweise in
malawi ist der brotpreis um 50 prozent
gestiegen das ist ein bisschen mehr wie
beim rewe für sie unter sind die leute
die sich das brot kaufen müssen die
haben sowieso kein geld um sich
überhaupt nahrungsmittel zu leisten das
ist der unterschied und das haben sich
immer noch nicht verstanden dass die
blogger von der afg
in subsahara afrika sind 144 millionen
menschen auf lebensmittelhilfe der
vereinten nationen angewiesen und das
könnte in den nächsten monaten 30 bis 50
millionen mehr werden und das
welternährungsprogramm muss jetzt mehr
bezahlen für das getreide dass es
sowieso kauft rund 30 prozent mehr der
finanzbedarf der ernährungssicherung
verdoppelt sich
alleiniger grund für den absehbaren
sturm des hungers ist der angriff krieg
putins auf die besten böden der welt die
ukrainischen schwarzerden ein angriff
auf die kornkammer der welt und die
zerstörung der dazu dienen infrastruktur
wie soll denn vorhandener weizen
überhaupt noch verschifft werden wenn
die häfen zerbombt und vermied sind
darauf geben sie in ihrem antrag liebe
cdu csu auch keine antwort und ich freue
mich auf den austausch in den
ausschüssen dann um über dieses thema
auch zu diskutieren
die humanitäre katastrophe
zeigt putin seine ganze
menschenverachtung mit seinem russischen
exportstopp für weizen gerste mais und
trocken weder uns europäer bestrafen
niemand anderes wie uns nein herr putin
nicht mit uns
hunger bedeutet der stabilisierung
unruhen kollaps von staaten ja das nimmt
putin bewusst in kauf er will eine neue
große flüchtlingsbewegung starten sie
soll dem erzfeind die humanitär
agierende eu an den rand der
möglichkeiten bringen und dort für
unruhe und spaltung sorgen das ist diese
menschen für echte strategie von herrn
putin nein herr putin nicht mit uns
und dem hunger sterben die ärmsten der
armen die schon vor dem krieg mehr als
die hälfte ihres einkommens ausgegeben
haben für essen nein herr putin nicht
mit uns was sind unsere waffen im krieg
gegen den hunger
kurzfristig und jetzt muss europa und
deutschland bedingungslos seine
nahrungsmittelproduktion steigern da
führt kein weg dran vorbei und das nicht
zu tun wäre eine zynische tödliche
überhebliche arroganz hier haben wir
geostrategische verantwortung
zweitens die zusätzliche finanzielle
hilfe der bundesregierung für das
welternährungsprogramm hat die
bundesregierung bereits auf den weg
gebracht mit 42 millionen extra hier
agiert die regierung völlig richtig und
das unterstützen wir von den freien
demokraten
mit der entwicklungszusammenarbeit wird
die koalition dafür sorgen dass die
eigenversorgung der länder verbessert
wird ertragreicher pflanzen eine
effizientere landwirtschaft und was
kurzfristig machbar ist sind bessere
lagerungsmöglichkeiten also hier können
wir auch ganz kurzfristig noch helfen
dass wir die lagerungsmöglichkeiten in
diesen ländern vereint verweisung
das sind unsere mittel gegen putins
morden
putins krieg gegen die ukraine ist ein
angriff auf die internationale
weltgemeinschaft
aber wir wir sind bei den mutigen
menschen die in der ukraine
auch europas freiheit und die der welt
verteidigen und bei all jenen
freiwilligen und hauptamtlichen die die
rein aller welt sich gegen diesen hunger
hunger stimmen die besatzung sei dank
[Applaus]
und das wort erhält der kollege arthur
auerhammer für die cdu csu fraktion
werde frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
berichten zufolge ist in der ukraine
noch eine fläche von 20 millionen hektar
nicht bestellt es fehlt an diesel fehlt
an dünger es fehlt an saatgut noch viel
schlimmer ist sehen die menschen die den
traktor fahren als im baum sitzen
und ich bin etwas verwundert dass man
diese debatte zu unseren antrag dann
auch dazu nutzt um alle themen jetzt
wieder aufzumachen und sich nicht
konzentriert auf die bewältigung dieser
humanitären katastrophe die auf uns
zukommt meine
meine sehr geehrten herrn
ich bin immer mehr verwundert über das
verhalten der fdp sie machen ja
teilweise kluge vorschläge aber sie
wissen schon dass ihr in einer
ampelkoalition zeit und ihr solltet euch
mal über die osterfeiertage mit
koalition eine eheberatung suchen oder
irgendwas damit es besser funktionieren
weil was wir in diesem land und was die
und kleinen gut gebrauchen kann ist eine
bundesregierung die nicht handelt wir
müssen jetzt anderen und es geht darum
dass wir dass wir unsere ökologischen
vorrangfläche nicht wir sind in
deutschland weit 170 tausend hektar und
ich gebe ihnen auch recht teilweise als
nicht sehr fdp sondern den grünen dass
nicht jeder quadratmeter effektiv zu
nutzen ist weil es grenzvertrag
standorte ist die habe ich selber ja
aber wenn die von 170 tausend hektar
100.000 nutzen kann auf 100000 hektar
lebensmittel produzieren kann dann habe
ich auch an den beitrag dazu geleistet
die welternährung zu sichern und wenn es
nur ein hektar ist und nicht nur wie sie
sagen man braucht hier mehrere andere
ansätze und ich weiß haben sie eine
zwischenfrage herr kollege
wenn die frau kinder ist mir glaubhaft
versichert sie hat eine nette frau
gedanken also ich hatte
als ich nehme das als ein java und
folglich
die nette frage ist möchten sie sich
nicht in einem redebeitrag auf was
anderes konzentrieren weil ich nämlich
gehört habe dass jetzt im bundesrat der
vorschlag von cem özdemir gerade
durchgegangen ist also der aufwuchs auf
den flächen und bestimmte anbau kann
stattfinden dann ist doch so weit erst
mal gut rechtlich zeitlich ist es eh
nicht mehr änderbar also lassen wir uns
über die zukunft reden und die bauern
werden diesen einen teil gerne nutzen
liebe frau plötzlich bin dankbar für
diese wette frage weil sie dazu mir mehr
redezeit geben ja wenn sie die beratung
im bundesrat verfolgt haben dann gab es
einen antrag der auf diesen flächen auch
landwirtschaftlichen nutzung zulassen
sollte mit den einsatz von
pflanzenschutzmittel mit den einsatz von
düngemitteln
diese ist abgelehnt worden und jetzt ist
nur
genehmigt worden dass nur die futter
nutzung von diesen flächen nutzen kann
jetzt schaue ich sie liebe frau künast
ich komme aus der landwirtschaft ich
kenne die
früchte die da drauf stehen auf diesen
flächen also ich weiß nicht ob so manche
iq begeistert ist wenn man sie mit
distel fördert also es ist kein beitrag
zur welternährung was sie hier leisten
wie diesen beschluss nicht wir brauchen
eine
aktivierung diese landwirtschaftliche
nutzfläche und schützen sie sich
widersetzten dankeschön
wir werden es ist ja auch so dass uns
die zeit davon läuft am 23 märz hat die
eu kommission hat brüssel bereits
beschlossen wir können diese flächen
nutzen vom 23 schmerz bis letztes
wochenende waren die besten aus hat
bedingungen in deutschland unsere
bäuerinnen unsere bauern hätten sehen
können sie hätten aber für ihre arme
frau künast auch serien können ja das
konnten sie nicht was sie es verhindert
haben in jeder bundesregierung
und
auch die eu hat vorgegeben es muss
innerhalb von 21 tagen entschieden
werden und der entschluss der jetzt im
bundesrat parallel gefasst es ist ein
minimalkompromiss
dem hier ja mittragen aber es wesen
werden wesentlich mehr drin gewesen
und wenn wir dann über die weitere
ausführung der agrarpolitik den nächsten
jahren reden dann ist ja auch klar die
forderung dass diese vierprozentige
stilllegung ab 2023 in der gap mal
hinterfragt werden soll
dann lasst uns doch darüber diskutieren
dass wir jetzt diese vier prozent
stilllegung nicht machen dass wir
nächstes jahr auch hier lebensmittel
produzieren und was ihn zwei drei vier
fünf jahren ist da müssen wir dann
wieder neu darüber diskutieren wir
hatten ihnen europa schon eine
stilllegung von zehn prozent können sie
vielleicht die nie ganz jüngeren noch
daran erinnern damals war die
stilllegung deswegen so hoch weil eine
überproduktion in europa stattgefunden
hat und jetzt müssen wir haben wir als
deutsche auch die verantwortung
lebensmittel zu produzieren für die
länder die es nicht mehr haben für die
länder die vom klimawandel betroffen
sind wir haben eine humanitäre
verantwortung hier als deutsche
bundestag auch meine damen und herren
und ich will ihnen das noch mal sagen
ich finde es gut wenn wir gewisse
ökologische maßnahme machen aber 1 stern
wir zurzeit auch auf den ideologischen
grünen spielwiesen da wächst kein
produkt getreide wissen muss uns klar
sein und die menschen brauchen jetzt
ernährung die menschen brauchen jetzt
was zum essen was so bringt viel dann
artur auernhammer aber dass es der csu
landwirtschaftsmeister und staatlich
geprüfter landwirt und wir kommen in die
schlussphase dieser debatte mit
franziska kersten die drittletzte
rednerin ist kommt aus der spd-fraktion
und ist mitglied im parlamentarischen
beirat für nachhaltige entwicklung und
das ist ganz interessant im parlament
hat dieser beirat eine sogenannte
wachhund funktion das heißt er im bild
in anführungszeichen natürlich nur
sobald ein vorhaben die nationale
nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
außer acht lässt an außer acht lässt mit
anhörungen und positionspapieren wurden
debatten beispielsweise angestoßen zu
und aus seiner sicht nötigen punkten und
jetzt die abgeordnete beteiligt sind der
krieg führt zu großem leid bei den
betroffenen ländern aber er kann auch zu
einer hungerkrise in der welt führen
zusammen mit den dürren mittelamerikas
afrikas und dem nahen osten kann eine
ernährungskrise entstehen die zu neuen
fluchtbewegungen führen kann was können
wir und was müssen wir tun zuerst geht
es um die hilfen für die geflüchteten
und die menschen in der ukraine
und da helfen wir selbstverständlich
jetzt schon auch die agrarpolitik muss
reagieren richtig ist dass deutschland
ein landwirtschaftlicher kunststandort
ist richtig ist aber auch dass wir mit
wetterkapriolen leben müssen hagel
starkregen und dass da mehr oder weniger
durchaus unsere erträge auch gefährdet
sind dagegen wurde unsere landwirtschaft
nur dann gewappnet sein wenn wir
resilient agrarische ökosysteme schaffen
das bedeutet regionalen er
stoffkreisläufe mit futter erzeugung und
immer verwertung vor ort zu schaffen und
breitere fruchtfolgen zu fördern wir
müssen die biodiversität als absoluten
entscheiden der widerstandsfähigkeit
unserer agrarsystem erhöhen das
erfordern die exzellenten
agrarwissenschaftler des landes schon
länger daher kann noch die konsequenz
aus der aktuellen krise nicht sein
produzieren um jeden preis und wir haben
die ganzen zahlen gehört 170 hektar und
was man da erzeugen kann und so weiter
wir können damit nicht tatsächlich den
welthunger so bewerten als dass es uns
eine langfristige perspektive gibt wir
müssen weg und futtermittelimporten aus
übersee und zu einer flächen gebotenen
tierhaltung kommen wir können vielleicht
eine zeitlich befristete abstimmung von
tierbeständen auch dazu führen dass er
weniger futtergetreide brauchen und dort
mehr für die ernährung anzubauen
vielleicht als tierärztin und rinder
züchterin kann ich sagen wenn sie jetzt
die vier millionen milchkühe
deutschlands mal einfach die reaktion im
kraft- oder um ein kilo kraftfutter
reduzieren dann würden sie ungefähr die
getreidemenge sparen die auf den
ökologischen vorrangflächen bei absolute
ausnutzung der fläche erwirtschaftet
werden könnte mama drüber nachdenken ist
vielleicht die varianten gut währung
ihre anstrengungen und jede form der
europäische agrarpolitik hin zu einer
der silly enten ein für kraftfutter ist
kein tierschutz keine tierschutz debatte
gar nicht gerne noch mal ein bisschen
nachlesen eine residente land und
ernährungswirtschaft anzuhalten oder
umzudrehen ist praktisch zum scheitern
verurteilt unbestritten ist die
verknappung von futtermitteln übrigens
im ökologischen bereichen auch stärker
als im konventionellen bereich und
darauf wurde er jetzt auch im bundesrat
die entscheidung praktisch durchweg dass
diese aufwuchs für futtermittel genutzt
werden kann und es sind hoffentlich
nicht nur disteln sie tun so als wären
es die besten flächen der land wurde ich
glaube jeder wirtschaften gelangt wird
weiß dass er da grenz ertrags standorte
nimmt und sie müssen nur mit datenschutz
mitte und düngemitteln die so auftreten
die sind aber teuer wie wollen sie das
finanziell ausrechnen wenn sie praktisch
da noch mehr aufbauen und dann erinnere
ich an das laufende
vertragsverletzungsverfahren vertrag ich
glaube dass die erhöhte düngung dieser
grenze standorte nicht dazu beiträgt
dass wir unsere die trat richtlinie
einhalten und das war möglicherweise er
die zahlung die zwangs zahlungen noch
eher befürchten müssen
sie müssen also schon will das ist ein
symbol politik ist übrigens stellt sich
auch die frage warum wir bei uns 80
prozent bankfähigen weizen produzieren
und nicht den eigentlich 30 30 prozent
von dem wir eigentlich die bäckereien
brauchen wir können also futterweizen
herstellen auf diesen flächen ohne
vermehrt dünger aufzubringen und sie
haben dann auch noch höhere erträge also
ist auch eine variante die sicherlich
gut ins bild passen würde
doch auf den flächen wo sie jetzt weizen
anbauen dürfen sie auch mit weniger
düngung einfach futterweizen anbauen und
nicht um alles nur auf diese absoluten
proteingehalt man muss aber und c weizen
mit einer proteingehalt von 11 prozent
hat höhere back fähigkeit als weizen mit
zwölf oder 13 prozent
ist mir noch besonders wichtig studien
haben ergeben dass fast die hälfte der
obst- und gemüseproduktion einer tonne
landet hier müssen wir ansetzen und hier
kann jeder einzelne schon heute mittag
seinen beitrag leisten um eine
nachhaltige klimaschonende
landwirtschaft und eine
ernährungssicherheit in einklang zu
bringen vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion erhält jetzt
das wort der kollege dr wolfgang
streifinger
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir nehmen es den hungernden um die
färbungen denn vor dem tod zu bewahren
diese aussage von verantwortlichen des
world food programms aus den letzten
tagen verdeutlicht in welcher
dramatischen situationen viele länder
vor allem auch entwicklungsländer sind
und diese aussage führt uns außerdem vor
dass dieser brutale angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine nicht nur unermessliches
leid für die bürger in der ukraine mit
sich bringt sondern auch in zahlreichen
entwicklungsländern den hunger
zurückbringt länder meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren die ohnehin oftmals zu
den ärmsten ländern der welt gehören in
denen mangelernährung auch zu normalen
zeiten keine seltenheit ist und auch in
länder deren finanzielle möglichkeiten
begrenzt sind schon auch aufgrund der
korona pandemie und jetzt heute kaum
noch vorhanden sind im libanon
ist eben seit ungefähr einer woche das
brot rationiert die preise um 20 prozent
gestiegen 66 prozent des weizens kamen
bisher aus der ukraine
in somalia sind die preise für weizen
300 prozent gestiegen tunesien libyen
gambia wie tagen ihren eritrea ägypten
die liste der länder die von hunger und
armut und auch von steigenden preisen
betroffen sind ließe sich also beliebig
fortsetzen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die ukraine wird aufgrund des
krieges größtenteils als weizen
lieferant in diesem jahr ausfallen und
die bilder aus den kriegsgebieten haben
wir alle vor augen aber auch die bilder
der hungernden menschen der hungernden
kinder und deswegen sage ich ganz
deutlich krieg ist mord und womit
wertmüller es zusagen auch hunger ist
mord
und
dieser hunger führt zwangsläufig zu
zunehmenden konflikten konflikte
bedeuten instabilität aufstände
gewalttätige auseinandersetzungen sind
die folge und ich darf im zusammenhang
auch der heutigen debatte an die
getreide preissteigerungen vor rund zehn
jahren erinnern und zu welchen folgen
diese geführt haben viele dieser folgen
beschäftigen uns ja auch noch heute und
deswegen ist es ehrlicherweise unredlich
frau düring wenn sie hier so diesem
moralischen zeigefinger
bringen und jetzt versuchen die klima
den klimawandel hieraus zu spielen sie
fliegen ja soweit ich weiß am
ostermontag nach mali vielleicht fragen
sie dort mal die mütter mit den
hungernden kindern was sie davon halten
dass ihnen der klimawandel gerade
wichtiger ist als die ernährung der
kinder und
ich sage ihnen ganz deutlich
ich sage ihnen ganz deutlich deutschland
und deutschland und europa müssen jetzt
handeln sonst die dafür dass die
potenziale ausgeschöpft werden können in
der landwirtschaft sorgen sie dafür dass
wir möglichst schnell auch den ländern
im globalen süden helfen können wir
müssen landwirtschaft wir müssen
ernährung und entwicklung zusammen
denken es braucht eine langfristige
strategie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
auch vor dem hintergrund des
klimawandels deswegen braucht es neben
dem vernetzten ansatz sicherheit und
entwicklung auch eine vernetzung von
agrarpolitik und entwicklungspolitik und
was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe frau
künast das world food programm auch
angesprochen dass ihre regierung
im aktuellen haushalt des
entwicklungsministeriums das world food
programme um 50 prozent kürzen dass ihre
regierung die sonder initiative eine
welt ohne hunger um 60 millionen kürzt
die aktuelle situation gebietet etwas
anderes und sie stellen sich hierhin
moralisch mit ihrem zeigefinger und
versuchen hier die großen reden zu
halten
ich sage ihnen eines co-präsidentin ich
sage ihnen eines natürlich kann man vom
geld nicht runterreißen aber es braucht
eben auch die potenziale in der
landwirtschaft und die müssen wir jetzt
heben und zwar schnell heben natürlich
auch in diesen ländern aber es muss
jetzt schnell gehen es muss jetzt
schnell gehen frau künast und deswegen
müssen wir hier zügig handeln sie müssen
handeln sie sind in der regierung es
reicht nicht immer nur zu warnen ihre
minister basis medizinischen handelns
sehen
da es kein stückchen dass die ihn wird
jetzt folgen die letzte rednerin in
dieser debatte die riaa türk nachbauer
nochmal spd fraktion
und als letzte rednerin in dieser
debatte erhält das wort die kollegin der
radweg nach bauer
hatte frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren viele punkte wurden heute schon
angesprochen
ich gehe jetzt den oder ich möchte im
fokus auf die themen welternährung und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit leben für uns
steht fest wir werden die menschen in
der ukraine nicht im stich lassen nicht
heute und nicht morgen
wäre wäre alles dafür tun dass die
ernährungssituation nicht nur vor ort
sondern auch weltweit stabil bleibt
zumindest vorerst stabil bleibt und wir
wollen sie auch verbessern aber nicht
nur wir als politikerinnen und politiker
im parlament und der regierung helfen
wie und wo wir können ich möchte an
dieser stelle auf meinen dank an die
vielen privatwirtschaftlichen
unternehmen aussprechen die bereits seit
wochen ihre fahrzeuge für den transport
von lebensmitteln und anderen
hilfsgütern in die kriegs gebeutelte
ukraine bereitstellen danke dafür
im landwirtschaftsministerium wird
ebenso mit hochdruck in der koordination
verteilung und des transports von
lebensmittel gearbeitet und es
funktioniert vielen dank dafür herr
bundesminister und das liebe bmv kofler
vielen dank wir konnten uns nämlich
selber ein bild davon machen als wir vor
einigen tagen in der grenzregion der
ukraine waren wie sie sehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union ihr
antrag kommt in einigen punkten etwas
verspätet auch ohne ihr einige ihrer gut
gemeinten hinweise hat ja wir kommen
zurück im bundestag letzten zwei drei
minuten in der debatte über
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit aber
auch in der ukraine am pult ist er ja
türk nachbauer für die spd-fraktion
euro angekündigt allerdings ist das nur
ein anfang ich möchte explizit betonen
dass auch die übrigen geberländer im
rahmen der g7 aufgefordert sind
ebenfalls noch erhebliche fehler noch
einmal die ausreichende finanzierung des
welternährungsprogramms die knie
insbesondere am herzen dieses programm
ist ein unabdingbares instrument zur
weltweiten bekämpfung von hunger und
mangelernährung
ich möchte nicht wieder die bilder und
die folgen der unterfinanzierung erleben
wie wir sie damals im syrien krieg
erlebt haben diese finanzierung
erfordert keine hochtrabenden titel oder
wohlklingenden namen wie wir sie
manchmal aus dem bmz früher gehört haben
denn es kommt allein auf den inhalt und
die wirksamkeit der finanzierung an
diese hilfe muss unbürokratisch und in
mit unmittelbar bei denen ankommen die
sie ganz dringend brauchen
so
fällt die umsetzung sind bereits seit
langem ein intensiver austausch zwischen
den beteiligten ministerien stadt darum
mussten keine sonderposten oder ganz
neue titel geschaffen werden vielmehr
waren sich alle beteiligten in dieser
regierung einig dass eine schnelle
unterstützung priorität hat ferner
planen wir neben bestehenden programm
der bilateralen zusammenarbeit weitere
maßnahmen diese werden auf lange sicht
die landwirtschaftliche produktion in
unseren partnern land sichern und sie
unabhängig von russischen derzeit
exporten machen ich glaube daran dass
eine welt ohne hunger möglich ist wenn
der politische wille da ist eine welt
ohne hunger ist auch der name eines
ernährungsprogramms und wird eines tages
hoffentlich realität werden auch trotz
der kriegs treibenden aggressionen
demokratiefeindliche diktaturen am ende
möchte ich von erbeten zu dem überleiten
dass jeder einzelne von uns jetzt tun
kann um jetzt weltweit den hungernden
menschen wenigstens minimal zu helfen
ohne viel aufwand ohne viel aufhebens
ich möchte an uns alle appellieren
lassen sie uns unsere eigenen
gewohnheiten bei der ernährung unter die
lupe nehmen das ist uns gemeinsam auch
im kleinen etwas verändern reduzieren
heißt nicht unbedingt verzichten
wir werden diese etwas aus der zeit
gefallenen antrag nicht zustimmen danke
der türke war die letzte rednerin in
einer debatte des bundestages zum thema
ukraine hilfe zur
nahrungsmittelversorgung weltweit aber
auch so lage der ernährungslage in der
ukraine jetzt wird abgestimmt
beziehungsweise überlegt ob diese
anträge die hier vorgelegen haben aus
der unionsfraktion und aus der fdp
fraktion überwiesen werden ihnen die
zuständigen ausschüsse oder ob sie hier
direkt abgestimmt werden wir haben mal
kurz rein was die vizepräsident erhöht
muss da zu sein und mit beratend an den
auswärtigen ausschuss an den ausschuss
für inneres und heimat an den
rechtsausschuss an den finanzausschuss
an den haushaltsausschuss an den
wirtschaftsausschuss an den
verteidigungsausschuss an den ausschuss
für arbeit und soziales an den
verkehrsausschuss an den ausschuss für
umwelt naturschutz nukleare sicherheit
und verbraucherschutz an den ausschuss
für menschenrechte und humanitäre hilfe
an den ausschuss für bildung forschung
und technikfolgenabschätzung
an den ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung an den
ausschuss für tourismus an den ausschuss
für die angelegenheiten der europäischen
union
dazu an den ausschuss für wohnen
stadtentwicklung bauwesen und kommunen
an den ausschuss für klimaschutz und
energie und an den ausschuss für
digitales
wer hat denn jetzt aufgepasst welcher
ausschuss war nicht dabei
ok also jetzt wieder ernsthaft wir
stimmen nach ständiger übung zuerst über
den antrag auf ausschuss überweisung ab
ich frage deshalb wer stimmt für die
beantragte überweisung
das ist die linke spd bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp wäre es dagegen
cdu/csu und afd damit ist die
überweisung so beschlossen und damit
stimmen wir heute über den antrag auf
drucksache 13 36 nicht in der sache ab
zusatzpunkt sechs interfraktionell wird
überweisung der vorlage auf drucksache
13 46 an die in der tagesordnung
aufgeführten ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungs vorschläge
dass es nicht der fall dann verfahren
wir wie vorgeschlagen
ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt
21 so decke wieder kurz erklären wie es
jetzt hier weitergeht die eben
diskutierten anträge werden also in
einer vielzahl von ausschüssen
weiterberaten werden wenn ich das jetzt
alles richtig verstanden haben und zwar
in einer fülle wie sie eigentlich
einigermaßen ungewöhnliches also im
grunde ist das ganze parlament jetzt mit
diesen beiden anträgen beschäftigt da
sind wir mal gespannt wie das hier
weitergeht jetzt geht es hier weiter mit
dem vierten corona steuer hilfe gesetzt
er wird gleich der bundesfinanzminister
als erster zu reden es geht um
beispielsweise
sonderleistungen von arbeitgebern bis
3000 euro die steuerfrei bleiben sollen
es geht darum die home office pauschale
zu verlängern es geht darum die
sogenannte degressive abschreibung von
wirtschaftsgütern zu verlängern erhoffen
wir uns ein bisschen aufklärung was ihr
das im einzelnen und besonderen ist und
es geht darum die verlustverrechnung zu
verlängern also viele milliarden die
auch der wirtschaft helfen sollen durch
die korona pandemie besser raus zu
kommen beziehungsweise wieder fuß zu
fassen
alles weitere jetzt vom finanzminister
und
der titel des gesetzes sagt bereit es
handle sich im steuerlichen
hilfsmaßnahmen es ist nicht die von mir
prinzipiell gewünschte
unternehmenssteuerreform und es sind
auch nicht die unternehmenshilfen die
robert habeck und ich heute mittag
vorstellen werden es handelt sich um
steuerliche
hilfsmaßnahmen aber dennoch will ich
denn natürlich eine maßnahme hervorheben
die wichtig ist die auch so nicht
geplant war und durchaus auch mit bezug
auf den wichtigen beitrag des kollegen
meister in der steuerpolitischen debatte
von eben mit den vorhaben und
entscheidungen der vorgängerregierung
wäre die degressive afa
anfang dieses jahres ausgelaufen in
einer situation wo wird tatsächlich
wirtschaftliches wachstum und
investitionen der privaten hand
stabilisieren müssen wäre das eine
falsche entscheidung gewesen und deshalb
sorgen wir mit diesem gesetzentwurf
dafür dass die degressive afa 2022
erhalten bleibt
und tatsächlich wollen wir darüber
hinaus noch eine sogenannte super
abschreibung machen deshalb habe ich
aber die spitzenverbände der deutschen
wirtschaft gefragt wollt ihr sie im jahr
2022 wollt ihr sie haben angesichts von
lieferengpässen wollt ihr sie haben die
möglicherweise auch inflation verstärken
könnte wollt ihr sie in diesem jahr und
die spitzenverbände der deutschen
wirtschaft wie bei mir im ministerium
waren haben unisono gesagt in diesem
jahr
2022 macht es keinen sinn und deshalb
werden wir uns dieses wichtige
instrument vorbehalten aber zu einem
zeitpunkt zu dem es wirklich wirksam ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich will
einen letzten punkt anschließen weil
auch eben in der debatte von kollegen
meister gefragt worden ist ja wo sind
denn eure initiativen für
wirtschaftliches wachstum und ich
unterstreiche dass ich glaube ein
wichtiger beitrag zum wachstum ist dass
wir das planungs und genehmigungsrecht
in deutschland so beschleunigen dass
gute ideen überhaupt schnell umgesetzt
werden können das hilft auch schon beim
wachstum kostet aber nichts darüber
hinaus aber hatte diese koalition 200
milliarden euro öffentliche mittel bis
2026 reserviert für energieeffizienz für
ladesäulen infrastruktur auch für fragen
der digitalisierung das ist unser
beitrag mit öffentlichen mitteln das
wachstum in deutschland zu stärken da
bewegen wir uns fiskalisch auch in einem
guten umfeld mit anderen
volkswirtschaften die es genauso machen
das halten wir für richtig das machen
andere genauso das sind erhebliche
mittel die das wachstum stärker und ich
frage mich die kammern als cdu/csu am
selben tag morgens im deutschen
bundestag maßnahmen für das wachstum
fördern und am mittag eine klage
vorstellen gegen den klima und
transformations- von der wachstumsstärke
das wort erhält für die cdu/csu-fraktion
der kollege olaf gute
frau präsidentin werde kolleginnen und
kollegen wir haben es da schon gehört
die bundesregierung muss zur bekämpfung
der folgen der korona pandemie schon zu
beginn dieser legislaturperiode einiges
tun allerdings mir fehlt der glaube dass
mit den jetzt vorgesehenen
minimalen und halbherzigen korrekturen
tatsächlich die wirtschaftlichen
einschränkungen die wir haben gelindert
werden können
gezielte förderung von unternehmen zu
ihrer wirtschaftlichen erholung das hört
sich gut an und das benötigen wir auch
dringend aber was bedeutet das in ihrem
entwurf das bedeutete aufguss der
maßnahmen des zweiten corona steuer
hilfe gesetzes verlängerung der verlust
verrechnungsmöglichkeiten
verlängerung der degressiven afa für
bewegliche wirtschaftsgüter sowie die
verlängerung der steuerlichen
investitions fristen bewährte maßnahmen
sicher aber eben nicht ausreichend was
bringt ein unternehmen
auf zwei jahre ausgeweitete verlust
rücktritt wenn eben nur die pandemie
bedingten verluste mit weiteren
verlusten verrechnet werden dürfen wir
fordern sie daher auf
den ertrag steuerlichen verlust rückgrat
zeitraum auf mindestens drei jahre über
die krisenjahre 2020 bis 22 hinaus
dauerhaft auszuweiten und auch die höhe
der höchstbetrags grenzen beim verlust
rück trag auf 15 milliarden über 15
millionen euro zumindest temporär zu
erhöhen und dann muss ich mal sagen sie
mehren hier immer um das hättet jedoch
die letzten 16 jahre alles machen können
jetzt muss man auch seien die letzten 16
jahre hatten wir eine durchschnittliche
inflationsrate von durchgängig weit
unter zwei prozent jetzt haben wir 7
jetzt stehen wir vor einer stagnation
aber sie gucken immer nur in den
rückspiegel und ich sage ihnen damit
fahren sie an die wand jetzt ist die
zeit zum handeln
jetzt brauchen wir mehr power jetzt
brauchen wir weniger zaghaftigkeit denn
nur so helfen sie denjenigen die
arbeitsplätze in diesem land schaffen
und erhalten und damit am ende auch den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern ja
es gibt kleine lichtblicke in diesem
gesetz die wir durchaus unterstützen wir
können zum beispiel die verlängerung der
förderung der steuerfreie zuschüsse zum
kurzarbeitergeld und die verlängerung
der bestehenden regelung zur home office
pauschale natürlich mit rat aber auch
hier bei der home office pauschale warum
schon wieder begrenzen entfristen sie
diese doch dass wir eine gute
signalwirkung für die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer und unternehmen in
diesem land rombach
wortreichen ankündigungen
nach wortreichen ankündigungen
insbesondere des
bundesgesundheitsministers schaffen sie
jetzt einen steuerfreien corona bonus
für besondere leistungen des
pflegepersonals
mit dem im gesetzestext allerdings
vorgenommen beschränkungen und ausnahmen
erreichen sie nicht den personenkreis
der tatsächlich zwei jahre lang
heldenhaftes geleistet hat die
regelungen für die steuerfreien bonus
zahlen von bis zu 3000 euro
sie sind zu kompliziert sie sind auf
einen zu kleinen kreis beschränkt und
sie sind insbesondere auch nicht mit den
öffentlichen arbeitgebern
abgesprochen die hier ja auch zahlungen
avisiert haben ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir alle pflegekräfte an alle
unterstützer für ihren einsatz
vernünftig honorieren das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber wir müssen
auch an alle anderen steuerpflichtigen
denken die aufgrund der hohen inflation
aktuell großen belastungen ausgesetzt
sind und deshalb fordere ich sie auf und
das haben wir auch schon mehrmals gehört
dass wir bei der einkommenssteuer eben
jetzt nicht nur schönheits operationen
vornehmen sondern dass der gesamte
einkommensteuertarif unverzüglich an
diese inflation angepasst wird mit der
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages ist es
nichts getan denn damit wird der tarif
gerade im eingangsbereich noch weiter
gestaucht das problem der kalten
progression wird dadurch noch verschärft
legen sie also diesen fünften
steuerprogression bericht jetzt vor
warten sie nicht bis zum herz herbst
sondern handeln sie jetzt jetzt haben
wir die belastungen und jetzt brauchen
wir die notwendigen tarifänderungen
machen sie die restaurierungs
begünstigungen endlich auch für kleine
und für mittlere unternehmen attraktiv
wir haben hierzu ja bereits vorschläge
gemacht sie lagen schon beim
bundesfinanzminister scholz auf dem
tisch jetzt liegen sie bei ihnen auf dem
tisch handeln sie endlich es ist
dringend notwendig diese testierung
begünstigungen attraktiver zu machen und
in weiterer punkt aus dem gesetz die
verlängerung der abgabefrist für die
steuererklärung
es ist natürlich richtig und gut aber
auch hier warum nur halbe kraft sie
wissen dass ohne gleichzeitige
verlängerung der offenlegung fristen für
die jahresabschlüsse die sache nur die
hälfte wert ist warum bleiben sie hier
auf der hälfte stehen und gehen nicht im
ganzen schritt man kann zusammenfassend
fest halten
die maßnahmen in diesem gesetz sind über
die räte zum beschluss und kollegen sie
bleiben aber auf halbem weg stecken sie
sind viel kosmetik sie reichen bei
weitem nicht aus um das erklärte ziel
dieses gesetzentwurfes zu erreichen wie
so oft too little too late ich freue
mich auch die anhörung die bringt
hoffentlich weitere erkenntnisse
wonach putin ist für die unionsfraktion
mitglied im finanzausschuss und
unüberhörbar unzufrieden mit einem
gesetzentwurf den die bundesregierung
vorlegt das vierte krone steuer hilfe
gesetzt dass nachteil
ausgleichen soll die durch die korona
pandemie entstanden sind anders lauten
jetzt mutmaßlich die argumentation von
asamoah aus der spd-fraktion damen und
herren die bundesregierung legt heute
neben dem steuerentlastungsgesetz mit
dem vierten corona steuer hilfe gesetz
ein weiteres wichtiges reformpaket forum
aktiv gegen die auswirkungen der
wirtschaftlichen großwetterlage
vorzugeben hat demi inflation fossile
inflation noch angetrieben durch die
spekulationsgewinne der
mineralölkonzerne sich verschärfende
lieferketten probleme uni
konjunkturellen folgen des furchtbaren
angriffskriegs von russland gegen die
ukraine lieber ermutigen das ist nicht
klein das ist nicht halbherzig das fügt
sich ein in ein gesamt
entlastungsvolumen von über 30
milliarden euro in diesem jahr und es
ist richtig gut und richtig viel
ich sprach über die gesamten maßnahmen
in diesem jahr die wir insgesamt greift
es fügt sich ein und müssen wir zu hören
in dieser lage ist es genau richtig
weiter das geld in die hand zu nehmen um
beschäftigte zu entlasten unternehmen zu
stützen und zielgerichtet zu investieren
wir wollen jobs wohlstand und existenz
in deutschland sichern und zu einer
volkswirtschaftlichen stabilisierung
beitragen so hier ist derzeit so wie es
derzeit auch andere europäische staaten
machen damit wir einer möglichen
stagnation bestmöglich entgegen wirken
denn dieses szenario würde uns besser
würde uns deutlich mehr belasten als die
investitionen die wir jetzt noch zu
abwehr vornehmen können liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die krisenfolgen stellen unser land auch
auf absehbare zeit vor große
herausforderungen bedürfen eine
abfederung da wollen die beschäftigten
selbstständigen unternehmen mit
steuererleichterungen
nicht mit der absolution jeglichen
akuten wohlstandsverlust verhindern zu
können dazu bedarf es einer
langfristigen dauerhaften strategie die
wir mit den maßnahmen 200 milliarden für
klima und energie einsparung unser paket
und vielerlei mehr parallel angehen
sondern entsprechend mit dem ansatz zu
unterstützen
deshalb ist es für uns eine absolute
selbstverständlichkeit die herausragende
leistung unserer pflegekräfte die sich
tagtäglich für unser gesundheitswesen
einsetzen in dieser pandemie am limit
arbeiten und erlauben sie mit dieser
bemerkung gestern von der union mit der
ablehnung der impfpflicht belohnt wurden
wenigstens finanziell zu würdigen mit
dem chor ohne pflege bonus der bis zu
einem betrag von 3000 euro steuerfrei
gestellt werden kann denn viele menschen
in krankenhäusern pflegeeinrichtungen
sehr gut gebrauchen können und auf der
grundlage unseres steuergesetze zu
erhalten das ist unfassbar wichtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
stabilisierend wirkt sich auch unsere
anstrengungen für das kurzarbeitergeld
aus wir wollen die steuerfreien
arbeitgeberzuschüsse bis ende juni
verlängern damit geben wir unternehmen
planungssicherheit und sichern damit
auch millionen von jobs diese maßnahme
ist wichtig denn das modell der
kurzarbeit wird in der aktuell
angespannten konjunktursituation die
wahrscheinlich noch in den kommenden
monaten bleiben wird ein sehr sehr
wichtiges instrument sein und wird
dringend gebraucht und das wissen wir
jetzt ampelkoalition liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und auch die regelung zum home office
gehen weiter unsere steuer zahlen können
damit dieses jahr für jeden kalendertag
den sie von zu hause arbeiten auch wenn
sie kein eigenes arbeitszimmer haben was
er gelegentlich der fall sein soll
geltend machen wir jetzt ampelkoalition
wissen dass der bedarf an mobilen und
digitalen arbeiten von zu hause während
der corolla pandemie stark zugenommen
hat oder auch in zukunft für die
beschäftigten und die familien ein ganz
wichtiges thema sein wird deswegen ich
glaube ich habe es heute schon den
meister gehört müssen sie uns nicht
auffordern uns damit auch nochmals
vertiefen zu beschäftigen lesen sie es
im koalitionsvertrag nach wir werden das
tun
auch für die unternehmen entscheidet das
vierte corinna steuer hilfe gesetz
präzise entlastungswirkung dazu gehört
als ein überaus wirksames instrument die
verlängerte und erweiterte
verlustverrechnung die sich ab 2022 ford
folgende dauerhaft auf die unmittelbar
zwei vorangegangenen jahre erstrecken
soll deutschland befindet sich mit
diesen maßnahmen unter anderem zur
verlustverrechnung als wirtschaftlichen
stabilisator auch im internationalen
umfeld ein guter gesellschaft und das
kombinieren wir mit der verlängerung der
steuerlichen investitions fristen für
reinvestitionen damit wir gerade die
liquidität von kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen stärken können
zu guter letzt möchte ich auch natürlich
auf die bereits heute mehrfach
angesprochene
möglichkeit ist auf die verlängerung der
degressiven abschreibung eingehen die
wir für das jahr 2022 vorsehen das trägt
auch zu einer schnellen refinanzierung
bei und schafft investitionsanreize ein
gutes stichwort für die im
koalitionsvertrag fest verankerte super
abschreibung oder auch investitions
prämien die in einen zeitraum nach 2022
kommen soll wir sehen darin große
potenziale um investitionen für die
digitale transformation und klimaschutz
zu mobilisieren und freuen uns heute
schon sehr auf die konzeptionelle
ausarbeitung des
bundesfinanzministeriums
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zu sehen
wir bündeln mit dem vierten corinna
steuer hilfe gesetz wirtschaftliche und
soziale maßnahmen und schaffen damit die
voraussetzung für eine echte
wirtschaftliche stabilisierung und
erholung auf diesen politischen kurs
können sich die menschen in deutschland
bei der ampel koalition verlassen auch
in schwierigen zeiten ich danke
casa maria spd fraktions hat liegt das
vierte corinna steuer hilfe gesetz ein
wortungetüm wir uns gelegentlich kennt
aus dem boden das teilt aber es soll
tatsächlich für entlastung sorgen bei
bürgerinnen und bürgern vor allem aber
auch in der wirtschaft nächster redner
albrecht glaser aus der afc fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine
herr abgeordneter ich bin nicht herr
präsident
wenn ich so gelaufen sein sollte habe
ich versprochen
wir beraten heute über das fertige oder
steuergesetz einmal abgesehen von der
völlig 100 gesamte absenkung der
umsatzsteuer und 20.20 für ein halbes
jahr die 20 milliarden euro
mindereinnahmen des staates geführt hat
geht es nun um die verlängerung von
maßnahmen die die vorangegangenen carola
steuergesetzen angelegt sind nichts
neues nichts aufregendes und schon gar
nichts fortschrittliches
ihre botschaften wie sie heute mittag
verkünden wurden in der öffentlichkeit
wäre natürlich schön wenn man sie heute
morgen im parlament gehabt hätten wo wir
doch so schön beieinander sind die
steuerliche freistellung von
sonderzahlungen an die beschäftigten die
bereich der krankenversorgung und der
pflege bis zu einem betrag von 3.000 die
verlegung der steuerfreistellung von
zuschüssen zum kurzarbeitergeld um sechs
monate bis ende 22 und die verleihung
der gewährung der home office pauschal
um ein jahr bis zum 31 dezember 22 zur
förderung von unternehmen sollen die
regelungen der degressiven abschreibung
um ein jahr längert werden ein erhöhter
verlängerte verlust rückfragen
verlängerte fristen für steuerliche
vergünstigung bei investitionen nach §
6b und 7 g des einkommenssteuergesetzes
sollen eben was eingeräumt werden
grundsätzlich stehen wir diesen
maßnahmen positiv gegenüber zu
kritisieren sind jedoch die inhaltlichen
mängeln der regelung die zögerliche art
der umsetzung in der gesetzesbegründung
ist von konsequenten maßnahmen die rede
und der absicht planungssicherheit zu
schaffen genau dieses leistet der
entwurf jedoch nicht warum wird erst im
april 22 über die steuerfreiheit von
kurzarbeitergeld entschieden dass in den
vergangenen monaten bereits gezahlt
worden ist warum beraten wir erst heute
über steuerliche förderung von corona
sonderzahlungen die bereits im letzten
jahr geleistet worden sind dazu kommt
die unbegründete vielleicht auf
verfassungswidrige ungleichbehandlung
von ähnlichen sachverhalten wäre die
bereits bestehende steuerfreiheit für
boni bis zu 1500 euro allen
arbeitnehmern zugute kam gilt die hier
vorgeschlagene steuerfreiheit für
weitere boni bis 3000 euro nur für eine
bestimmte berufsgruppe als ob
beschäftigt in anderen berufen nicht
auch den besonderen belastungen der
kroner krise ausgesetzt waren die
verlängerung der home office pauschal
ist nicht ausreichend weder in der höhe
von nur 600 euro noch in ihrer
zeitlichen streckung die arbeitswelt hat
sich geändert das wurde schon angedeutet
und deshalb ist eine weitreichende
reform für dieses thema von nöten wir
haben die afc bereits im dezember zwang
sich die modernisierung der antiquiert
antiquierten regelung zum häuslichen
arbeitszimmer gefordert drucksache 23
725 bei der hilfe unternehmen ist
ebenfalls mangelnden wirksamkeit zu
kritisieren die unternehmen dürften ihre
verluste für zwei jahre zurück tragen
dass es angedeutet worden was aber nützt
ein verlust rücktritt von heute in zwei
corona jahr die davor liegen in denen
gewinne gar nicht wirtschaftlich sind
worden sind vielleicht verlust
entstanden sind
[Applaus]
dann sähe anders aus und wie sie
aussehen könnten haben wir ebenfalls in
unserem antrag vom april 20 zum ersten
kroner steuergesetz in der beschriebenen
druck sei bereits gefordert dazu fordern
wir temporär abschaffen der
mindestbesteuerung ich höre es nicht
wäre eines der wichtigsten im falle von
nicht ausgeglichenen verlusten
hochaktuelles thema ein verlust rückgang
mit verlängerten zeitraum auch bei der
gewerbesteuer innere davon nichts wäre
außerordentlich wichtig und aussetzung
der zinsschranke volle berücksichtigung